Es ist wieder Ligatour-Zeit, wir blicken auf den europäischen Fußball und diesmal gleich in 5 Ligen in die Ehredivise La Liga, Serie A, Ligue 1 und Premier League jetzt hier im Rasenfunk und los geht's! Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich begrüße hier bei mir in Reihenfolge ihre Bildschirme hier bei mir auf dem Monitor. Daniel Zander, guten Morgen Daniel.
Moin, moin moin.
Jakob Hafke ist da, Sauber Jakob.
Moin.
Mario Rieker, so ein bisschen wie eine Anwesenheitskontrolle. Schön, dass du da bist.
Anwesend.
Ebenfalls zum Dienst erschienen Chris McCarthy.
Hi.
Und Nils Kern ist auch da und wunderbar zu verstehen. Hallo, Nils.
Hallo, Herr Lehrer.
Ja, okay, also das war awkward, aber gut, irgendwie will ich euch ja alle zu Wort kommen lassen, bevor wir dann loslegen, denn sonst der letzte, der dran ist, der hat ansonsten gefühlt erst mal eine halbe Stunde geschwiegen. Naja, muss ich mir vielleicht noch was Neues überlegen. Nils, du warst der Letzte, der sich vorgestellt hat, der mich begrüßt hat, deswegen darfst du jetzt auch anfangen. Wir blicken mal nach Spanien. Du hast zwei große Themen mit dabei, mit welchem magst du denn beginnen?
Ja, das eine große Thema ist vielleicht das, was jetzt noch aktuell ist und war. Vom Wochenende gab es ein bestimmtes Spiel, ein Spitzenspiel in Spanien, was jetzt immer noch ein paar Nachwehen hat, wie so immer. Eigentlich reden wir von einem klassischen Clásico, im Sinne von, dass es während des Spiels schon mal zwei aberkannte Tore gab, dann ein zurückgenommener Elfmeter, ein verschossener Elfmeter, am Ende gibt es noch eine gelb-rote Karte. Natürlich gehört auch eine Rudelbildung, eine saftige zu einem klassischen Clásico, auch wenn da jetzt keine Fäuste geflogen sind. Aber da reden wir schon mal über viel Action, wo es immer wieder hier und da Provokationen gab. Mittlerweile ist es in La Liga ja so, dass überall Lippenleser angestellt sind und dann wird geschaut, wer hat zuerst weh in den Handschlag vielleicht verweigert oder wer hat zu wem welche Geste gemacht. Also da sind ein bisschen natürlich die Gemüter hochgekocht, nachdem der FC Barcelona in der Vorsaison alle vier Clásicos aus teils deutlich gewonnen hat. Jetzt mal wieder Real Madrid für einen verdienten Sieg gesorgt. Das ist 2-1 ausgegangen, hätte auch gut vielleicht noch ein 4-1 werden können. Aber Kilian Mbappé steht immer noch gerne mal im Absatz viermal in dem Spiel. Von dem her gibt es da ein paar Themen von diesem Spiel. Jetzt habe ich noch gar nicht große, wenigstens Auswechslung erwähnt. Erst mal nur Clásico. Wer es gesehen hat, denkt sich, ist eigentlich wie immer, wie früher zu Mourinho-Zeiten, jetzt auch wieder mit ein bisschen mehr Würze drin.
Aber was sind denn für dich da die wichtigeren Themen? Denn ich habe dieses neben dem Platz habe ich alles mitbekommen. Nach dem Spielergebnis musste ich übertrieben gesagt googeln.
Oh, das ist bezeichnend dafür, dass eigentlich Real Madrid hat ein gutes Spiel gemacht. Wir können auch darüber reden, was Xabi Alonso hier und da schon verändert hat, was man jetzt auch mal wieder in einem Top-Spiel gesehen hat, nachdem Real ja auch da die letzten Male öfter mal verloren hat. Ja, und trotzdem reden irgendwie fast alle über Vini Cisjuni und die Auswechslung. Ich würde noch anfangen mit eben oder überleiten zu dem Vini-Thema nochmal sagen, dass es unter Alonso hier und da schon ein anderes Real Madrid ist. Also es gibt sportliche spielerische Elemente. Man hat vorne ein geschlosseneres Gegenpressing. Das war unter Ancelotti mehr so individuell. Wer will, der darf mal draufgehen. Das Real Madrid-Spiel ist flacher geworden, weniger Flanken, auch weil man jetzt keinen klaren Neuner vorne hat. Generell wirkt das Team wieder ein bisschen geeinter. Mehr Intensität, mehr Motivation, weniger Fehler. Da war es in der Vorsaison oft noch ein bisschen zu locker. Generell auch die Ancelotti-Art und Weise ist er. Er hat ja immer ein sehr freundschaftliches Verhältnis zu seinen Spielern. So ein Valverde und Vinicius, da ist ein Ancelotti ja fast eine Vaterfigur für sie. Und jetzt unter Xabi Alonso ist es da ein bisschen mehr Disziplin angesagt. Im Training wird nicht immer nur zwei in der Mitte die Rondos gespielt, sondern auch mal verschiedene andere Trainingsübungen durchgeführt. Also es weht ein anderer Wind bei Riamar Ritten. Das bekommt jetzt speziell auch ein Vinicius Junior zu spüren. Wir reden über 13 Pflichtspiele diese Saison. Von denen hat er nur drei durchgespielt. Sieben oder zehnmal Startelf. Er ist nicht immer mega gesetzt. Er ist meistens schon in der Startelf, wird meistens ausgewechselt. Das war jetzt auch ein Klassik. Der Fallen ist jetzt– davon habt ihr wahrscheinlich alle am meisten gesehen und mitbekommen. Jetzt gab es gestern am Mittwoch auch noch die Entschuldigung von Vinicius, weil er ist bei seiner Auswechslung. Man kann mal stinkig rausgehen und sagen, eigentlich hätte ich gerne weiter gespielt, weil er hat ein gutes Spiel gemacht. Man hat gerochen, da geht noch ein Tor vielleicht für ihn. Da war er schon mal stinkig. Er ist dann direkt in die Kabine, ohne abzuklatschen. Das ist eigentlich auch schon No-Go. Dann hat er von den Dzone-Kameras aufgefangen und auch noch gesagt, warum immer ich, ich gehe jetzt, ich haue ab. Nach dem Motto, ich habe keinen Bock mehr, ich verlasse Real Madrid jetzt, wo er bei seiner Entschuldigung am Mittwoch klargestellt hat, dass ein bisschen die Leidenschaft mit ihm ist, ist da durchgegangen. Er hat sich dann intern beim Team entschuldigt und möchte sich auch noch mal öffentlich entschuldigen bei den Fans und beim Präsidenten und generell beim Club. Zum Club gehört zwar auch der Trainer nur, aber der Trainer wurde jetzt noch nicht explizit erwähnt. Das ist gerade so ein bisschen das Zündstoffmaterial, weil wie gesagt, unter Alonso ist er nicht immer primär gesetzt. Da ist jetzt Mbappé, der Hauptelfmeter schützt. Da gab es in der Vorsehsaison auch noch viele Diskussionen. Es ist alles ein bisschen mehr Disziplin und Ordnung unter Alonso als vielleicht noch unter Ancelotti. Das spürt ein wenig Süß. Da war jetzt eben, wie gesagt, das ist immer noch das große Aufregerthema.
Und glaubst du, das ist was, was die Liga auch möchte, dass so viel über Nebenthemen gesprochen wird? Das ist ja schon interessant, dass es ums Sportliche wirklich fast gar nicht ging, jetzt in dem Clásico.
Ich glaube, von der Liga kommt das jetzt nicht groß aus. Das ist ein gefundenes Fressen für die Medien. Und wie gesagt, wenn Winni da normal runtergeht oder vielleicht auch mit einem Minifazette abklatscht, dann ist das kein Thema mehr. Dann reden alle darüber, wie Xabi Alonso Real Madrid verändert hat und wie es mal wieder ein Topspiel gewonnen wurde, nicht wie das Derby oder gegen PSG, wo man ja deutlich verloren hat. Von dem her ist das so eine große Sache. Aber jetzt nicht, glaube ich, wo sich La Liga die händere. Also in der Liga oder in Javier Tebas wird sich schon immer denken, okay, alles, was gegen Florentino Perez ist, ist gut für ihn. Auch da haben wir ja später noch ein Thema, was in La Liga los war. Aber ich glaube, Mario hat es sich gemeldet.
Ja, ich wollte zwei Sachen dazu loswerden. Also zum einen, weil du es gerade auch schon gesagt hast, mit Winnie, man kann immer mal rausgehen und verärgert sein. Ich finde es, aber was halt wirklich überhaupt gar nicht geht, das ist so ein wichtiges Spiel, auch muss dann ja vermeintlich für einen Spieler wichtig sein. Dann gucke ich mir das gefälligst von der Bank aus zu Ende an und will, dass meine Mannschaft gewinnt. Das ist Punkt eins. Und das zweite, was du schon angesprochen hast, ist mir in den Wochen, weil ich real einmal meine Champions League-Konfi hatte und sie davor mir ein bisschen angeguckt hat, ist ja immer die Frage bei solchen Kader und Persönlichkeiten. Kader-Management. Und vielleicht spürt es Winnie in negativer Hinsicht, aber ich habe schon auch den Eindruck, dass es Mbappé stärker gemacht hat, dass er ein bisschen gepudert worden ist. Davon kannst du halten, was du willst, dass so ein Spieler dann noch irgendwie vom Trainer hier, du bist die Nummer 1 gesagt, bekommt. Aber das war ja irgendwie auch bei PSG schon so und das gehört irgendwie zu seinem Charakter auch dazu. Und dann finde ich, ist das eine Anpassung, nur so auf Kader-Management-Ebene von Alonso, die offensichtlich schon gegriffen hat.
Ja, da ist er auf jeden Fall. Mbappé ist der neue Zielspieler. Wie gesagt, letzte Saison gab es viele Diskussionen, wer darf jetzt einen Elfmeter ausführen? Jetzt ist es primär Mbappé aus. Er schenkt mal Winnie ein. Da gab es jetzt auch mal letztens ein Spiel. Und ja, jetzt hat Winnie nicht mehr so die ganz hohen Karten, großen Karten Ballon d'Or noch zu gewinnen, was ja irgendwo sein Hauptziel ist. Und damit muss er sich abwinden. Und trotzdem, wie gesagt, unter Alonso viel Positives, auch viel mehr Rotation. Ich glaube, durchschnittlich 3,5 Änderungen in der Startelf pro Spiel. Und fast immer die Wechsel auch alle ausgeschöpft. Das ist auch schon mal ein bisschen anders, als es noch unter Alonso war. Du hast immer noch ein paar Dauerbrenner. Couture keine Minute verpasst. Dann kommen schon Mbappé und Juve und Winnie mit den meisten Minuten. Aber es ist nicht mehr in Winnie, es ist nicht mehr in Valverde, die die meisten Minuten abrocknen. Von dem her hat Alonso schon viel zum Positiven verändert, was vielleicht eben oder offensichtlich nicht jedem gefällt. Jakob hat auch was.
Da wünsche ich mir nur ganz kurz, da wünsche ich mir schon irgendwann von Max auch ein Ballon d'Or-Special vom Rasenfunk. Ich finde, das ist schon ein Kanonmal.
Du hast mein Augen rollen genau gesehen, Mario. Aber da sticht er da nochmal rein. Ja, also wenn es hier das Ballon d'Or-Special gibt im Rasenfunk, dann könnt ihr mich abmeldet. Dann könnt ihr mich vom Podcastbetrieb abmelden. Dann wurde ich entführt und will ein Zeichen setzen. Jakob.
Ich wollte noch mal zur Mbappés-Rolle. Du hattest ja gesagt, dass Alonso es schon hingekriegt hat, dass die Mannschaft ein bisschen geschlossener spielt, gerade auch gegen den Ball und funktioniert das mit Mbappé wirklich auch. Ich habe jetzt nur in der Champions League Real mal gesehen. Aber bei Frankreich ist es ja immer wirklich krass, wie er vorne einfach nur rumsteht und ab und zu mal einen Schritt nach links, einen Schritt nach rechts. Und das ist jetzt aber bei Real anders.
Ja, also Situationen mit Ball, wenn hinten aufgebaut wird, dann ist er schon weiter vorne und darf geschickt werden mit seiner Geschwindigkeit. Aber es gibt auch Szenen von ihm oder Bilder. Das war ab dem Beleg, glaube ich, letztes Jahr am Finale, wo er so bei einem Abschluss des Torwartes irgendwie da vorne am Strafraum lauert und so richtig fixiert. So ähnliche Szenen gibt es auch von einem MVP mittlerweile. Das hat ein Schabier schon hinbekommen, dass man jetzt wieder einfach wieder ein bisschen geeinter, lustvoller, galliger sich präsentiert auf dem Platz. Da macht auch mal ein Winnie mit und Bellingham sowieso. Also es ist schon da besser geworden, was jetzt nicht heißt, dass MVP die ultimative Pressing-Maschine geworden ist. Aber es gab schon gute Bilder aus dieser Saison, wo dann auch mal hinten mal mit der Ball erobert wird von einem MVP. Das kommt jetzt eher selten vor, weil, wie gesagt, mit seiner Geschwindigkeit soll er schon vorne lauern und warten und darf sich auch mal rausnehmen. Aber es ist besser geworden auf jeden Fall.
Ganz kurz, wir sind schon relativ weit fortgeschritten, aber wir können jetzt ja auch nicht gar nicht über Barca sprechen. Was ist denn für über die zu sagen nach dem Clásico?
Barca erstmal hatte jede Menge Ausfälle, sieben Stück von Lewandowski, Raffinha, Dani Olmo, Christensen noch, Hansi Flick auf der Tribüne nur gewesen. So war Markus Sork hat ein Clásico mal geleitet, auch nicht schlecht. Ja, Barca spürt so ein bisschen die Intensität der Vorsaison im Sinne von Hansi Flick, super intensive Spielgabe, viele Sprints, viele Zweikämpfe, auch nur ein Halbzeit 2 geführt, auch starkes Pressing. Da merkt man aktuell, es häufen sich aktuell ein bisschen die Verletzungen vielleicht auch dadurch. Und einerseits mit Inigo Martinez ist der Abwehrchef im Sommer gegangen, so gab es jetzt sehr viele verschiedene Abwehrvarianten von der Viererkette, mit auch verschiedenen zwei Innenverteidiger Duos. Und letztes Jahr war eben Kubasi Martinez genial für diese Abseits-Falle, was kein Team so richtig entschlüsselt hat, außer einmal Celta mit einem Borja Iglesias-Hat-Trick, haben trotzdem verloren. Und das ist aktuell, merkt man so ein bisschen die Teams kriegen es raus. Sevilla hat so 4-1, glaube ich, deutlich gewonnen. Girona hat verloren, aber die hatten auch 4-5 Top-Chancen. Raiu Vaikano hat es gut gemacht. Und auch Real Madrid ist immer mal wieder dahinter gekommen. Von dem her, das wirkt so ein bisschen entschlüsselt und sorgt, sagte selbst, es ist schwierig jetzt Dinge zu verändern. Sie wollen das durchziehen. Also ist das so ein bisschen leichtes Himmelfahrtskommando. Sie sind ja trotzdem Tabellen zweiter, 5 Punkte hinter Real Madrid. Das ist jetzt noch nicht tragisch. Auch mal in der Champions League vielleicht noch spät gegen PSG zu verlieren. Aber auch die Niederlage war irgendwo verdient und kam auch genauso durch dieses Abseits-Fall hoch. Hakimi außen durch, muss nur einmal dann ins Zentrum ablegen, wo der Mittelstürmer gezockt hat, schon gelauert hat im Abseits. Und dann hat Ramous da noch das 2. gemacht, von dem her spürt Barca so ein bisschen. Okay, wir sind ein bisschen entschlüsselt. Wir haben durch die Intensität ein paar mehr Verletzte plus unser Abwehrchef fehlt. Mal gucken, wie wir das auffallen können. Da gibt es gerade ein paar Baustellen, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass sie dann um die Champions League-Plätze fürchten müssen. Wie gesagt, der Meisterschaftskampf, 5 Punkte, ist noch alles drin.
Eben, und ich denke, da tröstet sicherlich auch ein Blick in die Bundesliga, wo man ja sagen muss, der FC Augsburg, das ist ja das Barca Deutschlands, der hat ja ganz ähnliche Probleme mit einer hohen Verteidigungslinie und auch bei Spielern mit ähnlicher Qualität. Kriegt es auch nicht in den Griff. Wer dazu mehr wissen will, habe ich gestern Abend eine Sendung zu aufgenommen im Bundesliga-Männer-Feed. Da könnt ihr zu anderthalb Stunden hören, wo wir uns vor allem aufs Sportliche konzentriert haben und nicht so sehr auf die Sprüche, die es ja auch gibt von Sandro Wagner. Aber das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema. Das ist also der Klassiker. Dann wollen wir mal nach England blicken. Chris, da gibt es ein Team, das zwischen all den Titelfavoriten, die Punkte liegen lassen, sehr beständig punktet und auch erst 3 Gegentreffer in der Liga kassiert hat. Ich spreche von Arsenal. Überrascht dich das, dass die so souverän jetzt mit 4 Punkten Vorsprung vor Bournemouth, hatten wir alle auf unserem Bingo-Zettel vor dieser Saison, die Premier League anführen?
Nein, mich überrascht es nicht. Ich hatte vor der Saison Arsenal und Liverpool so ein bisschen gleich auf als Topkandidaten für den Titel. Mich überrascht eher Liverpool, aber dazu können wir später noch ein bisschen was erzählen.
Arsenal ist eigentlich genau so, wie erwartet.
Sie haben die tiefste Mannschaft der Liga. Was ein bisschen neu ist, ist, dass man auch die Siege einfährt, wenn man einen schlechten Tag erwischt hat. Und das war in der Vergangenheit bei Arsenal nicht so der Fall. Gerade, wenn die Konkurrenz geschwächelt hat, da hat man im letzten Jahr immer die goldenen Chancen liegen lassen. Und ja, anders als City, anders als Liverpool, die ebenfalls schlechte Tage am Wochenende hatten, hat man den Sieg eingefahren. Einen dreckigen Sieg gegen Crystal Palace. Und das Thema auf der Insel ist nicht, dass Arsenal das jetzt kann oder Lob dafür bekommt, sondern man bekommt ein bisschen Kritik dafür, ein bisschen Spott, dass man eben nicht schön Fußball spielt, dass man sehr defensiv ist und dass man sich auf Standards konzentriert.
Ja, okay, gut. Ich meine, klar. Aber andererseits, so wenige Tore hat ja Arsenal jetzt auch nicht geschossen. Ich meine, da ist halt 1-5-0 gegen Leeds mit dabei. Aber 16 Tore ist ja auch in Ordnung nach neuen Spielen. Ist denn– also woher kommt denn dieser Spott? Ist das vielleicht nicht einfach nur ein Coping-Mechanismus, weil man es nicht anerkennen will, dass man so gerade erfolgreicher ist als mit manch anderem Fußballstil?
Ja, also das ist auch so ein bisschen meine Meinung. Ich habe dazu eine Kolumne auch geschrieben. Und genau das ist auch so ein bisschen mein Gefühl. Ich meine, es sind zwar 11 Tore, sind Standards gewesen aus 16.
Das ist viel. Und es ist auch eine fantastische Defensive.
Du hast im Monat Oktober einen Schuss aufs Tor zugelassen.
Oh Gott, das ist wild.
Absurd.
Was?
Und das war eine abgefälschte Flanke. Also das ist schon absurd. Und gleichzeitig musst du aber auch sehen, dass du die meisten Ballkontakte in der Box hast, du hast 60 Prozent Ballbesitz, zweitmeisten Schüsse, nur 0,5 pro Spiel, weniger als der erste. Und es ist ja dann wahrlich kein Defensivfußball. Es ist ja Offensivfußball. Es ist ein dominanter Fußball. Und ich glaube, diese Hämel, dieser Sport, dieses Reduzieren auf Standards kommt einfach daher, dass man sich die Statistiken anguckt, dass man dann sieht, okay, die erzielen immer nach Eckwellen Tore. Und das ist ja auch der Fall. Nur muss man dazusagen, man merkt, dass Arsenal noch nicht an seinem Leistungsmaximum angekommen ist. Genauso wie Liverpool und City, nur hat Arsenal Wege gefunden, das zu kompensieren. Martin Uelgaard fehlt seit einiger Zeit wieder, war immer wieder verletzt. Er ist dieser Mann, der diese Räume findet, auch wenn er letztes Jahr ein schlechteres Jahr hatte.
Kai Havertz fehlt momentan.
Und auch wenn man Jörg Kärres geholt hat, er wäre meiner Meinung nach Stammspieler aktuell, weil es wird einfach ein bisschen unterschätzt, was für ein spielintelligenter Spieler er ist. Er schafft die Räume, er bringt seine Mitspieler gut in Szene. Und ich glaube, das sind so zwei Spieler, die dann die gegnerischen tiefen Blöcke aufreißen werden und für mehr Chancen aus dem Spiel heraus sorgen würden. Weil man merkt, Arsenal spielt die höchste Verteidigungslinie und erzwingt die tiefsten Defensivaktionen der Liga. Das heißt, dass die Mannschaften sich schon hinten reinstellen und es wird einfach viel häufiger zur Ecke geklärt oder an Freistöße erzwungen. Sie haben die meisten Ecken der Liga und dann ist es ja nur opportunistisch, dass du diese Ecken auch ausnutzt. Und es ist ein Weg, das zu kompensieren. Und meiner Meinung nach nicht eine Änderung der Philosophie oder ein hässlicher Fußballstil, sondern einfach wie gesagt opportunistisch und ein Weg, das zu kompensieren, bis man sein Leistungsmaximum aus dem Spieler aus erreicht hat.
Und wie wird das bei Arsenal selbst im Umfeld und so weiter wahrgenommen? Weil wir haben jetzt ja mehrmals schon, also im Grunde die letzten zwei Jahre, haben wir Arsenal schon gesehen, wie sie so angeklopft haben mal an der Meisterschaftstür und eben inzwischen wundern wir uns auch nicht mal, dass sie wieder Champions League spielen, so wie früher. Aber es war ja tatsächlich noch eine Nachricht vor einiger Zeit. Wie wird das denn jetzt gerade begleitet? Ich meine ein Oktober mit nur einem Schuss aufs eigene Tor, das ist ja tatsächlich krass.
Ja, also es gibt ein paar Leute, die sich so ein bisschen davon anstecken lassen, ob das Ganze nachhaltig ist mit diesen ganzen Standardtoren. Aber wie gerade gesagt, schätze ich schon, dass das nachhaltig ist bzw. dass das eher eine Übergangsphase ist. Und man muss ja auch dazu sagen, diese Standards, das ist ja kein Glück.
Also das ist einstudiert.
Du hast mit Nicolas Juve wahrscheinlich mit dem besten Standard-Coach in Europa. Und ich habe auch eine interessante Statistik gesehen. Seit 2023 hat Arsenal die meisten Tore nach Ecken geschossen, 37. Jetzt ratet mal ganz kurz, wer auf Platz 2 ist in Europa.
Leverkusen?
Gladbach. Fand ich auch ganz interessant. Aber ich meine, wenn man sich die Standards anschaut, es ist ja auch sehr kreativ. Es ist immer wieder was Neues. Es ist auch in Perfektion umgesetzt und dementsprechend ist es auch einfach eine Qualität. Und im Umfeld sieht man, glaube ich, aktuell, dass diese Mannschaft jetzt einfach auch reif geworden ist. Sie ist reif für den Titel. Sie weiß auch mit schlechteren Situationen umzugehen, mit Drucksituationen umzugehen. Und anders als in den letzten Jahren hast du auch einfach diese absurde Tiefe im Kader. Du kannst wirklich jeden Spieler ersetzen. Du hast auch dieses Jahr schon Spiele ohne Saka, ohne Saliba, ohne Ödegaard, ohne Havertz gehabt. Und nur dieses Jahr redet man nicht davon, weil du trotzdem die Siege einfährst.
Ja, wirklich sehr interessant. Ich meine, man könnte natürlich auch sagen, dass man jetzt zuletzt auch nicht mehr die ganz großen Namen als Gegner hatte, aber damit würde man dann vielleicht auch wirklich Crystal Palace auch nahe treten. Und ehrlicherweise man hat ja auch schon gegen City gespielt und gegen Liverpool und einmal knapp verloren gegen Liverpool und einmal knapp unentschieden gespielt gegen City, aus der anderen Richtung knapp, würde ich sagen. Können wir uns auf jeden Fall alle schon mal im Hinterkopf behalten. Ende November wird Arsenal zu Hause gegen Bayern spielen und da wird wahrscheinlich die schreckliche Champions League-Bilanz wieder zitiert werden von Arsenal gegen Bayern. Und alle, die diese Sendung jetzt gehört haben, wissen, das spielt vielleicht nicht so die große Rolle, denn das ist ein anderes Arsenal, was da auf Bayern trifft. Bin ich sehr gespannt drauf. Also das ist Arsenal aktuell 4 Punkte Vorsprung in der Premier League. 6 Punkte sind es schon auf City und auf Liverpool, sogar schon 7 Punkte über die sprechen wir dann später noch. Jetzt wollen wir aber mal auf die Eredivise blicken, Daniel, wenn du magst. Auch da haben wir ein Überraschungsteam, über das wir reden können.
Genau, und zwar Groningen. Die sind auf Platz 5, immerhin schon 10 Spieltagen mit 18 Punkten. Und auch halten noch Anschluss nach oben. Also nur 1 Punkt hinter Ajax auf 4, nur 3 Punkte hinter AZ auf 3. Also die sind da wirklich gut dabei. Und es ist bemerkenswert, es ist der Aufsteiger von vor 2 Jahren. Also die hatten vergangene Saison, haben sie sich souverän gehalten mit 39 Punkten. Das waren auch 15, 16 Punkte vor dem Kollegationsplatz. Also das war doch sehr entspannt für Groningen. Und die kontinuierliche Arbeit zahlt sich da jetzt aus. Und ich habe also ein bisschen geguckt, woran liegt das eigentlich. Und da muss man sagen, der Vorwurf an Arsenal, um mal die Rücke zu schlagen des nicht so schönen Fußballs, der ist bei Groningen vielleicht noch eher ein bisschen berechtigter. Also die Spiele sind so ein bisschen Horst Fischer, Union Berlin, Prime. So ein bisschen in die Richtung geht das bei Groningen. Auch mit dem ehemaligen Erfolg wie damals unter Horst Fischer. Das heißt, die Defensive steht im Fokus. Und die haben in den zehn Spielen dreimal zu Null gespielt und viermal nur ein Gegentor bekommen. Und die einzigen beiden Spiele, wo sie wirklich dann vier bekommen haben, waren auch gegen PSV, was okay ist bei der Qualität, die PSV hat, und gegen AZ, die ja aktuell auf drei stehen. Also gegen die Top-Teams der Liga hat es dann nicht so funktioniert defensiv, aber gegen den bisherigen Rest schon. Und dreimal zu Null viermal nur ein Gegentor für ein Team, was immer noch relativ neu in der Liga ist nach dem Aufstieg, ist eigentlich echt schon gut. Und das funktioniert vor allem deshalb, weil es kompakt verteidigt wird. Also, was Fischer hatte damals auch, glaube ich, bei jedem Spiel achtmal gesagt, die Kompaktheit. Und das ist bei Groningen eigentlich ähnlich. Die haben dann 4-2-3-1 mit Dachshund 6. Das ist auch so ein Trend in der RR-Divise, den ich jetzt so ein bisschen gesehen habe, dass eigentlich sehr viele Mannschaften dieses 4-2-3-1 hier zu wählen. Selbst Ajax, die ja eigentlich lieber 4-3-3-Team waren, haben jetzt unter Heitinker auch mal ein bisschen in die Richtung agiert. Und das funktioniert bei Groningen sehr, sehr gut, weil sie auch gerne mal die Bälle einfach lang hinten rausschlagen, weil sie wirklich auch in der Offensive relativ früh hinten aushelfen, lange Wege gehen, all diese Fähigkeiten tun. Und weil sie auch so eine Mischung aus Talent und Erfahrung in der Abwehr haben. Also, die haben auf den Außen einen Rente, das ist ein Deutscher, ist 28, haben einen Pärsmann links, der ist 34, haben aber ein IV-Duo aus 19 und 20 Jahren. Also, das ist für eine krasse Mischung. Aber es funktioniert gut mit dieser Mischung aus Erfahrung und Talent. Und auch gerade der IV Janze, der ist ausgeliehen von Ajax, in dem waren auch Top-Teams in der Eredivise her. Er hat sich dafür Groningen entschieden, weil er gesagt hat, ok, da habe ich auf jeden Fall bessere Chancen, vielleicht auch einen Stammplatz mir zu erspielen als bei Feyenoord oder PSV. Und der macht die Sache echt gut für 19 Jahre. Den wünschen sie sich jetzt in Ajax auch zurück, tatsächlich mit der Übersicht, die er schon hat und mit der Abwechslung, mit der er schon agiert. Das ist echt erstaunlich. Und das funktioniert, funktioniert echt gut. Und auch der Torwart hinten im Tor, der ist auch schon an die 30, das ist Fessen. Und der hat auch sehr präzise Bälle, lange Bälle, die er schlagen kann. Der ist der Spielintelligent. Und das ist die Abwehr, ist da das Prunkstück von Trainer Dick Lückin. Und das funktioniert echt gut. Und was auch auffällig ist, dass sie auch dann letztendlich auf Sieg spielen. Also es gab noch keinen Unentschieden. Es waren sechs Siege und vier Niederlagen. Und wenn sie mal in Führung gehen, dann haben sie den Hang dazu, dass sie eher versuchen, das Ergebnis zu halten, dass sie hinten dicht machen. Wenn sie aber dann mal zurückliegen, dann schalten sie auch um. Auf Offensive gehen deutlich mehr Risiko, was dann eben auch in vier Gegentoren mündet, bei PSV und AZ. Aber bei den Teams auf Augenhöhe hat es dann oft dazu geführt, dass sie eben doch noch mal den Punkt geholt haben, dass sie eben doch noch mal in der achttigsten, 85. 2-1 machen. Und das zahlt sich dann aus in der Tabelle.
Und mit Marco Rente, jemanden, der kommt aus der zweiten, vom BVB, war dann bei Herra Clás und jetzt spielt er eben bei Groningen. Und es ist Stammspieler, habe ich richtig verstanden?
Genau, der beackert die rechte Seite hinten, macht das sehr gut und ist auch aufgrund seiner Erfahrung in dem Team eben relativ von großer Bedeutung. Also er ist 28, ist eigentlich im besten Fußballer-Alter, wenn man so schön sagen möchte. Hat aber, wie gesagt, auch dieses Infantalliga-Duo neben sich, die sehr jung sind, hat auch vorne in der Offensive, ich habe mal geguckt in der Startausbildung jetzt im Spiel gegen Zidharth, war der älteste Offensive 22. Also der Stürmer vorne, Van Beren, ist nämlich 21, die Offensive-3er-Reihe ist aber irgendwie 22. Und dann braucht man auch einen, und der macht das sehr gut. Auch niederländisch ist er auch schon länger, wie du schon gesagt hast, in der Eredivisie und ist eine solide Bank, das würde ich so sagen.
Also kann man so sagen, die Rente ist sicher?
Oh Gott, wenn man so möchte, ja.
Like, wer es noch kennt. Schon ein bisschen älter. Okay, sehr schön. Aber kannst du mir noch kurz was sagen? Was ist Groningen für einen Fußballstandort? Ich glaube, deutschen Fußballfans wird er wahrscheinlich vor allem bekannt sein als Heimatverein von Ajan Robben, der dort sowohl seine Karriere begonnen hat, als auch sie dann beendet hat. Aber was gibt es denn darüber hinaus, zu Groningen zu sagen?
Groningen ist ein Traditionsverein, ein absoluter Traditionsclub. Und es war auch schon ein Schlag ins Gesicht für viele, dass sie dort abgestiegen sind. Vollkommen zu Recht, das ist eine andere Geschichte. Die reihen sich dann noch ein bisschen ein in die Traditionsclubs, wo dann viel auch falsch gelaufen ist, wo missgewirtschaftet wurde, wo man vielleicht auch ein bisschen über die Ansprüche gelebt hat. Das haben sie jetzt unter dem Trainer-Dicklöckchen wieder korrigiert. Und zwar in einem sehr erheblichen Maße. Das war der direkte Wiederaufstieg, jetzt die solide Saison, jetzt die Saison, wo sie echt gut dastehen. Und es ist in den Niederlanden eigentlich immer noch klar, hast du die großen Namen mit Ajax, mit PSV, aber Groningen ist vom Namen her, kommt dann direkt dahinter. Und viele sagen, die gehören einfach in die Eredivisi aufgrund ihrer Status. Das stimme ich voll zu. Das ist ein Kreditionsklub, das ist für Almen, für Groningen im Norden des Landes. Und da hast du natürlich auch ein paar Fußballvereine, so Herrenfeen ist ja noch ein bisschen nördlich. Aber ganz im Norden bei Groningen ist das auch gar nicht mehr so viel. Das ist eine sehr ländliche Gegend. Und da fungiert Groningen schon so als Leuchtturm und schon so als Identifikationsverein für die Gegend, weil da einfach an Top-Klubs dann nicht mehr so viel ist. Es ist kein großes Land, du kannst relativ schnell hinfahren, wo was ist. Aber es ist schon für die Umgebung da oben im Norden wichtig, Groningen. Deswegen freut es mich auch, dass die nicht nur in der Liga sind, sondern dass sie eben auch gerade so erfolgreich sind. Und dass sie auch trotz dieses Labels aus Fischerball durchaus auch in der Offensive zu begeistern wissen, sie haben diese jungen Offensivtalente, das sind Taha, das ist ein Thunderwerf. Und die bringen sie oft in so Eins-gegen-Eins-Situation. Und da sieht man dann schon, was die echt drauf haben an Triplings, an Zweikampfverhalten. Das funktioniert gut. Und diese langen Bälle sind auch ziemlich– gerade auch die, die die IV spielen. Die langen Bälle sind sehr präzise, da werden die Lücken gesucht. Und wenn dann es gelingt, dass diese offensiven Talente in diese Eins-zu-eins-Situation kommen, dann haben sie auch gegen ja fast alle Teams aus der Serie Divise echt eine gute Chance da nach vorne zu kommen. Und das sieht dann auch wieder schön aus. Schlimm– Anführungszeichen– schlimm wird es, wenn es nicht verteidigt wird.
Ja gut, so ist das halt. Alles kann man ganz, ganz selten haben. Okay, also der FC Groningen auf Rang 5. Wir wissen jetzt, warum. Und jetzt reden wir endlich mal über Trainerwechsel. Wir beginnen damit in Frankreich. Jakob, bei der AS Monaco gab es den ersten Trainerwechsel. Und das ist ja auch völlig logisch. Denn wenn ich mir die Tabellensituation angucke, dann liegt Monaco auf einem peinlichen zweiten Platz. Einen Punkt schon hinter PSG, bei denen ich nicht weiß, wann die zuletzt was gerissen haben. Also Gott sei Dank ist Adi Hütter weg.
Ja, es ist schwer zu beurteilen, nur anhand der Tabellensituation. Das ist ja allgemein in Frankreich gerade so ein bisschen die Lage, dass alles sehr, sehr eng zusammen ist. Also jetzt nach dem gestrigen Spieltag stehen zwischen Platz 1 und Platz 6 sind nur zwei Punkte. Und da springt auch alles hin und her. Also Monaco ist jetzt gestern auch mit einem spektakulären 5 zu 3 in Nantes dann auf Platz 2 gesprungen, waren vorher 6 da. Aber auch zum Zeitpunkt, als Adi Hütter entlassen wurde, war es jetzt nicht so, dass es jetzt ergebnistechnisch gar nicht lief. Ich meine, da waren sie vierter zu dem Zeitpunkt, hatten auch so ein paar Spiele ein bisschen glücklich gewonnen. Da hat unter anderem der Neuzugang an zu Fati, der ja gekommen ist, der sicherlich vielen was sagen wird, ein paar Tore gemacht. Das hat es jetzt in den letzten Wochen auch wieder weniger geworden. Aber rein die Ergebnisse waren jetzt nicht unbedingt die Gründe für die Entlassung von Hütter. Sie haben dann auch eine Rolle gespielt, weil kurz bevor er entlassen wurde, haben sie gegen Lorient verloren, gegen einen von den drei Aufsteigern, dann in der Champions League gegen Brügge sich eine sehr deftige Pleite abgeholt und dann in Überzahl nur unentschieden gegen Nizza gespielt, die zu dem Zeitpunkt auch noch schlechter dastanden, als sie es jetzt tun. Die sind ja jetzt auch als Achter schon in Schlagdistance wieder zur Tabellenspitze fast schon. Aber es kam vieles zusammen. Und ich glaube, einer der größeren Faktoren ist aber, den ich auch schon ein bisschen nachvollziehen kann, dass man irgendwie nicht so richtig wusste, wohin es gehen soll mit Hütter bei Monaco. Also es war von der Spielweise her eigentlich immer das Gleiche. Und man hatte auch nicht das Gefühl, dass man wirklich so die Schwächen, die man ganz, ganz deutlich hatte, dass irgendwas dagegen getan wird oder dass man zumindest versucht. Und es hat auf jeden Fall nicht geklappt, was an den Schwächen zu ändern. Also es ist so, dass die Defensive eigentlich schon immer ein Problem ist. Es gibt wahnsinnig viele individuelle Fehler immer wieder bei Monaco. Und das war in den, wer war jetzt insgesamt, war das ja jetzt seine dritte Saison. Und das war in allen Saisons ein Problem. Man muss ja auch sagen, zuvor ist er auch zweiter und dritter geworden. Also auch da rein vom Tabellenstand her völlig im Soll, glaube ich, was man erwarten kann auch in Monaco. Aber ich glaube, zum Problem ist einfach geworden, halt die Art und Weise, dass man nicht das geführte, dass die Mannschaft so richtig lernt, die gerade in der Viererkette viele Abwehrfehler, er hat auch relativ stringent an seinem 4-4-2-4-2-2, also so einen relativ typischen RB-System festgehalten, hat da wenig dran geändert und hat es aber einfach nicht vermocht, da auch der Mannschaft Stabilität zu verleihen, was vielleicht ein bisschen für ihn eher spricht oder sein das ein wenig entschuldigt, dass Monaco auch durchaus Verletzungsprobleme hat oder hatte. Also Dennis Zakaria, der Kapitän und so ein bisschen der Chef im Mittelfeld, fehlt verletzt jetzt auch immer noch und fehlte auch schon, als er entlassen wurde. Jetzt ist auch Eric Dyer verletzt, der ja auch so ein bisschen vielleicht als Routinier geholt wurde, um auch der durchaus jungen Mannschaft, also nicht auf allen Positionen, aber ein bisschen Stabilität zu verleihen. Es fehlen auch noch andere Spieler verletzt. Gerade in der Verteidigung sind auch immer wieder welche angeschlagen. Lukas Radetzky, der im Tor eigentlich dem Team Stabilität verleihen sollte, weil Philipp Köhn eigentlich auch seit Jahren ein Sicherheitsrisiko darstellt, ist auch schon schwer verletzt, hat zwei, drei Spiele zum Saisonstart gemacht und fehlt jetzt aber auch schon wieder lange und kann somit dann da auch nicht helfen. Aber ich glaube, ausschlaggebend war dann einfach so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass man irgendwie nicht mehr so wusste, wohin entwickelt sich dieses Team unter Hütter und wohin soll es gehen? Und deswegen hat man ihn dann auch rausgeschmissen.
Und glaubst du, das wird jetzt dann besser werden unter dem neuen Trainer?
Ich sag mal so, der neue Trainer bietet zumindest mehr Raum für Fantasie an, wo es hingehen könnte. Also ich glaube, es ist ja durchaus auch nicht unwichtig. Das ist natürlich zuallererst, das ist Sebastian Pogonjoli, also auch ein alter Bekannter aus der Bundesliga, als der letzte Saison mit Union Saint-Gélois in Belgien Meister geworden ist und man auch so mitbekommen hatte, dass er da erfolgreich wird, haben sich wahrscheinlich viele auch gewundert, dass der jetzt schon Cheftrainer ist an der Seitenlinie. Der ist auch wirklich ja noch sehr jung, ist 38 erst, hatte auch nur eine Saison als Chefcoach bei Union Saint-Gélois, war davor unter Alex Plessin Assistent auch und auch Jugendtrainer und hat das schon gut gemacht. Ich meine, er hat die erste Meisterschaft seit Ewigkeiten geholt bei Saint-Gélois und ich glaube, so ein junger Trainer projiziert dann einfach auch mal nochmal ganz andere Hoffnungen auf die Fan-Basis, auf die Vereinsführung und alles und dementsprechend kann ich den Gedanken dahinter schon verstehen. Ich glaube, wenn man in Belgien Meister wird und dann so jung ist, gilt man schon allein dadurch wahrscheinlich als einer der größten Trainertalente in Europa.
Ich sehe schon die Headline. Poconoli füllt endlich start Louis Deux 16.000 aus der Rand-und-Band.
Ja, wenn er das schafft.
Also ich sage mal so, solange Paul Simonis, der Gauda-Gardiola es nicht schafft, den Wölfe-Park, wie ich ihn jetzt einfach mal nennen möchte, auch nur annähernd zu füllen. Aber es ist ja im Grunde ein endlicher Move. Deswegen komme ich jetzt auch quasi auf diesen Quervergleich zwischen Poconoli und eben Paul Simonis. Das sind sehr junge Trainer, die einmal Erfolg hatten in einer Liga oder einem Wettbewerb, wo man sagen muss, es ist logischerweise nur nicht höchstes Top-Niveau in Europa, aber es ist auch nicht nichts. Und dann probierst du es einfach. Und ich weiß nicht, kann man schon erste Eindrücke jetzt aus seinen ersten Spielen ziehen?
Es ist schwer zu sagen. Also es lief ja ganz gut. Also man hat im ersten Spiel noch einen späten Ausgleich kassiert gegen Angers. Dann hat man in der Champions League sehr unglücklich, nur unentschieden gespielt gegen Tottenham. Also hat da eigentlich Tottenham über 90 Minuten hergespielt und hätte das Spiel 3-0 auch durchaus gewinnen können. Und das wäre absolut nicht unverdient gewesen. Dann hat man in der Liga einen wichtigen Sieg gegen Toulouse gefeiert. Den ersten Sieg dann nach fünf Spielen in der Liga und vor allem auch mal zu Null gespielt. Aber ein Problem, was sich auch bei Monaco durchzieht, dass man vorne sehr verschwenderisch ist. Das gab es auch im Spiel gegen Toulouse. Und das war jetzt tatsächlich auch trotz der fünf Tore gestern gegen Norton Faktor, dass man auch sieben oder acht hätte machen können. Und man hat sich halt auch drei wieder gefangen. Und da war auch teilweise wieder ein bisschen Slapstick dabei. Beim 2 zu 2 ist auch Philipp Köhn, der jetzt natürlich wieder im Tor steht, der Ball durch die Hände gerutscht. Dann ist er vom Pfosten geprallt und dann haben sie ihn nicht geklärt gekriegt. Und dann ist er irgendwie über die Linie gerutscht. Also es hat sich jetzt noch nicht so vieles verändert, aber ja, ein bisschen was umgestellt hat er schon. Er hat das System gewechselt. Monaco spielt jetzt 3-4-3 mit ja so zwei Zehnern Halbflügelspielern. Ist immer so ein bisschen unterschiedlich, wer da spielt. Also Minamino sieht man da zumindest zum Beispiel häufiger. Aklius, über den wir ja auch im Frankreichsegment, meine ich, kurz gesprochen hatten, als wir die Sendung so ein bisschen anders gemacht hatten. Der war jetzt gestern gegen Nantes zum Beispiel auch sehr stark. Und ich glaube schon, dass das ganz gut funktionieren kann. Und vor allem finde ich sehr spannend, wie es ist. Also ich habe das Spiel gestern gegen Nantes auch über 90 Minuten gesehen. Und man hat auf der eigentlich Wing-Wag-Position mit Krippin Diata und Uwe Tara 2, die eigentlich gelernte Flügelstürmer sind. Also es ist dann auch teilweise sehr offensiv besetzt personell. Und das sieht schon nach vorne echt gut aus teilweise. Also gestern hat man auch sich so viele Chancen auch teils echt schön herausgespielt, hat einige auch wirklich krass vergeben, was auch so ein bisschen was ist, was sich durch die Saison zieht. Also Mika Bioretz, der in der letzten Saison oder in der letzten Rückrunde alles kurz und klein geschossen hat, hat, glaube ich, in 15 Spielen 13 Tore gemacht für Monaco. Und der ist in dieser Saison noch gar nicht dabei. Ist jetzt auch unter Pocognoli vorerst immer nur Ersatz und kommt dann kurz vor Schluss von der Bank. Auch Folarin Balogun, der eine richtig gute Saison hatte in der Ligue 1 bisher mit Stad Rens, ist jetzt so langsam aber sicher, kommt da wieder in Form, hat gestern auch getroffen, hat aber auch eine Riesenchance vergeben, wo er frei vorm Torwart den Ball irgendwie zehn Meter drüber geknallt hat, ohne zu übertreiben. Aber ich glaube schon, dass es besser werden kann und zumal, wenn dann auch ein paar von den erfahreneren Spielern wieder zurückkehren, also zum Beispiel einem Eric Dyer kann ich mir auch vorstellen, dass der gerade in einer Dreierkette der Mannschaft echt Stabilität verleihen kann. Muss man auch dazu sagen, dass das unter Hütter in einer Viererkette nicht so gut funktioniert hat. Fand ich jetzt auch nicht so überraschend, ehrlich gesagt. Und Zachariah wäre super wichtig, wenn er wieder fit ist. Und dann natürlich das, worauf eigentlich alle warten, seitdem er im Sommer geholt wurde, dass Paul Pogba endlich seine ersten Minuten sammelt. Das Comeback ist ja immer weiter verschoben worden. Eigentlich sollte er im Oktober schon spielen, nachdem man im Sommer recht schnell kommuniziert hatte, dass es illusorisch ist, dass er zum Saisonstart schon in Spielform ist. Aber jetzt soll es tatsächlich am Wochenende so weit sein, dass er gegen Paris FC im Kader stehen könnte. Mal schauen, ob er dann auch die ersten Minuten sammelt. Und natürlich ist das eine, ja, ziemliche Überraschungsbox, sage ich mal, was man dann letztendlich bekommt. Und ich glaube nicht, dass wir jetzt direkt den Pogba von 2018 als der Weltmeister geworden ist mit Frankreich wiedersehen.
Warum auch?
Aber ich sage eben, ja, ich sage mal so, selbst wenn er ein paar Klassen schlechter ist, ist es natürlich schon jemand, der der Mannschaft sowohl mit seinen Fähigkeiten als auch mit seiner ja durchaus inzwischen auch vorhandenen Erfahrung nochmal ganz neue Elemente geben kann. Weil momentan spielt man auch im zentralen Mittelfeld mit ja Talenten und so ein bisschen umgeschulten Spielern, also Jordan Tese spielt da, der ist eigentlich Außenverteidiger, macht das trotzdem ganz gut. Mamadou Koulibaly, finde ich sehr interessant, hat jetzt gestern auch gegen Nantes ein Tor vorgelegt, ein Tor selbst gemacht, ist auch erst 21. Aber halt auch so ein bisschen die Routine fehlt der Mannschaft gerade so im Zentrum momentan sehr durch die Ausfälle dann auch. Aber ich glaube, dass man durchaus darauf hoffen kann, dass es auch bald besser wird oder beziehungsweise sogar noch besser wird, weil wir haben es ja schon gesagt, sie sind ja auch auf Platz 2, haben den zweitbesten Sturm, allerdings halt auch schon 16 Gegentore kassiert in 10 Spielen.
Wir schauen uns an, wie sich das da entwickelt und von Paul Pokba zu Juventus Turin und von einem Trainerwechsel zum anderen Trainerwechsel ist der Weg wirklich nicht weit. Mario, die Zeit Igor Tudors bei Juve, sie ist vorbei. Warum?
Das hat keiner kommen sehen. Also ich habe gerade noch mal geschaut, ob der neue Trainer schon verkündet wurde. Das ist nicht der Fall. Deswegen würde ich es gerne einmal ganz weit hinten aufzäumen, verspreche aber, mich kurz zu halten und sehr populistisch dafür zu sein.
Das Gegenteil vom Rasenfunk. Kurz halten und populistisch.
Aber mach. Ich glaube, bei Juve geht das Problem los mit der Verpflichtung von Cristiano Ronaldo. Das ist schon ein paar Jahre her. Damals hat man sich eigentlich das erste Mal entschieden, einen Schritt zu gehen, hin zu einer neuen Philosophie. Man hat mit Maurizio Sarri ein absolutes Fußball-Chinni, meiner Meinung nach, geholt. Der, das hat mir letztens auch ein Spieler erzählt, der damals im Kader stand, selbst ihm noch sehr viel Taktik vermittelt hat. Aber menschlich ist er halt relativ schwierig. Also wenn du dazu dann einen Spieler wie Cristiano Ronaldo holst, stellt euch das Bild vor, Sarri auf dem Trainingsplatz noch mal Taktik-Schulung geben. Macht CR7 damit oder eher nicht? Das hat also nicht funktioniert. Allerdings hat Sarri zumindest noch geschafft, die letzte Meisterschaft 2020 mit Juve zu holen. Also das steht auf seinem Briefkopf. Danach ist man dann den Weg gegangen, dass man einen vermeintlich neuen, aber mit großem Namen geholt, Andrea Pirlo, dessen erste wirkliche Trainerstation das war. Da hat man wirklich einfach nur, glaube ich, viele Brüderschaften und Glaube daran, dass Andrea Pirlo das halt macht, wegen Name und Ruf etc., Premier geholt, hat nicht funktioniert. Dann Back to the Roots, Max Allegri, alles wieder sozusagen resettet, Altbacken, viel Defensivfußball, wenig Chancen für Jugendspieler. Also man hat eigentlich einen Aufbruch, den man starten wollte, im Keim erstickt. Und ist dann, nachdem das mit Allegri auch gar nicht mehr funktioniert hat, aufgrund von persönlicher Zerwürfnisse etc., dann doch noch mal auf einmal diesen mutigen Schritt gegangen und hat Thiago Mota geholt. Der hat viel Freiheiten bekommen, auch auf dem Transfermarkt mit einem neuen Sportdirektor. Das war irgendwie das, wo alle dachten, mich eingeschlossen. Ja, das ist jetzt mal ein neues Juve, die bekommt eine neue Identität, etwas, das vielleicht langfristig angelegt ist. Auch da hat es nicht so sein sollen. Thiago Mota davor eine gute Saison, da sind wir wieder bei diesem Thema mit Bologna gehabt. Und wohl, was man auch sonst zu hinter den Kulissen gehört hat, das eine oder andere Mal menschlich schwierig, nahezu abgehoben wurde, ihm da auch unterstellt. Und da Juve auch sehr viel Geld verbrannt hat, auch im letzten Transferfenster mit Thiago Mota schon, zum Beispiel sein Wunschspieler Toinkopp Mainers. Wir haben ihn alle, glaube ich, noch vor Augen bei Atalanta in seiner Prime, da irgendwie 44 Torbeteiligungen, 129 Spielen, das ist eine ganz gute Quote. Bei Juve ist schon 55 Mal gezockt, 8 Torbeteiligungen, also das hat nicht funktioniert. Und dann ist man wieder diesen, ich fand diese Tudor-Installation ist eigentlich Allegri 2.0, das ist einer, der den Verein kennt, der sich angeboten hat, gesagt, komm, ich mach das bis Saisonende. Hat sie noch auch mit teils dann ihr destruktiven Fußball, aber ergebnisgetrieben in die Champions League geführt, was für Juventus extrem wichtig war, aufgrund dieser hohen Ausgaben in die Champions League zu kommen. Und jetzt kommen wir zum aktuellen Problem. Bei Juve sind natürlich auch immer noch handelnde Personen. Am Start wie zum Beispiel ein Giorgio Chiellini, der auch sehr viel, glaube ich, über das Herz kommt. Mal kennenlernen dürfen, sehr sympathischer Kerl, aber der lebt halt auch den Verein und der hat jetzt auch nochmal betont, wie, was für ein großer Juve-Mann Tudor war oder ist. Also ist diese Vertragsverlängerung– und du machst das auch in der neuen Saison, obwohl man auch schon und dann noch zwei, drei gute Spiele bei der Club WM schon auch, glaube ich, zum Großteil dahingehend getroffen worden, weil man gesagt hat, der hat es sich verdient und das ist ein Juve-Mann und guck mal, der hat uns in die Champions League geführt. Aber ob da so richtig die Idee zur Weiterentwicklung da war, weiß ich nicht. Und auch teilweise auf dem Feld und dann auch daneben so ein bisschen mutlos agiert. Und jetzt steht man vor einem Neuanfang des Neuanfangs. Umbruch kann schon was werden, aber auch mit der großen Hypothek, dass man unfassbar viel Geld verbrannt hat in den letzten Jahren. Alleine die Herrschaften Motta und Tudor, wenn sie die nicht irgendwie bei einem anderen Verein unterbekommen oder Auflösungsverträge gebacken bekommen, wo ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob Motta das macht, schleppen die wahrscheinlich bis 2027 noch 30 Millionen aus dem Verein raus. Man hat letzten Sommer für Douglas Lewis über 50 Millionen Euro bezahlt. Man hat mit dieser Kaufpflicht für Lewis European da. Zahlt man auch fast 50 Millionen. Also sorry, so viel Geld nach Leipzig überweisen. Allein dafür sollte man schon gesteinigt werden eigentlich. Und der hat auch noch gar nichts abgerufen. Und dann hat man trotzdem eigentlich auch eine Menge an potentiell jungen, guten Spielern gehabt, die man verscherbelt hat. Man hat Hausen für 10 Millionen oder so abgegeben, weil man zu dem Zeitpunkt jede Münze gebraucht hat, um dann eben diese Nonsenstransfers zu machen. Weil natürlich ist in Italien auch immer ein großes Thema die Bilanz. Aber 10 Millionen für einen eigenen Jugendspieler sind halt 10 Millionen, die du sofort einbuchen kannst.
Genau, musst nichts abschreiben für.
Und ja, dass der vielleicht noch in Bangola, damit einmal Werder gemenschen wird, auch für 10 Millionen sozusagen abgegeben, wo viele Juve-Fans schon auch gesagt haben, naja gut, es könnte schon auch einer sein, den man irgendwie in drei Jahren vielleicht hätte für 40 nach Wartford verkaufen können oder zu PSG oder whatever, na. Also viel, das, ja das Lustige ist im Übrigen, das muss ich einmal kurz mitnehmen, ohne jetzt das Familienmitglied schämen zu wollen, dass mir diese Post-its geschenkt hat. Ich habe gerade die Juwelen verscherbelt auf ein kitschiges Post-it geschrieben, wo unten, da stehen immer noch so lustige Wand-Tätow-Sprüche drauf. Ein Leben ohne Träume ist wie ein Garten ohne Blumen. Also Juve fehlen die Blumen.
Also Viktor Bonifay ist auch nicht gekommen.
Das willst du doch damit sagen. Ja, Juve fehlen so auf jeden Fall ein wenig die Blumen. Ich habe aber schon auch Hoffnung darauf, dass jetzt rechtzeitig die Reißleine gezogen wurde und wenn Lucianos Balletti kommt, da etwas aufgebaut werden kann. Also wahrscheinlich bekommt er einen Vertrag bis Ende der Saison, was ja auch erstmal ein gutes Learning ist. Und sollte Allegri dann die Minimalsaison ziele mit Juve bis Sommer, also heißt Champions League Qualifikation erreichen und einen neuen Vertrag bekommen, würde ich mich so weit aus dem Fenster lehnen und sagen, dass Juve dann nächste Saison mit Balletti für mich Topkandidat auf die Meisterschaft ist. Weil ich ein ganz großer Fan bin von Luciano Sballetti. Klar, da gibt es jetzt auch irgendwie diese Nebengeschichten. Er hat sich nach der Meisterschaft bei Napoli den Scudetto tätowieren lassen, mit Napoli-Logo drüber. Napoli-Juve, die Napoli-Fans sagen jetzt auch wieder, du Heuchler, weil ich mir denke so, mein Gott, das ist ja halt…
Komm, ey, Markus Baben hat es auch nicht geschadet.
So, so, so. Und bei Lucianus Balletti, der hat damals 2016 war das, also auch innerhalb einer Saison, bei der Roma übernommen, hat da auch schon unter Beweis gestellt, dass er auch in einer laufenden Saison eine Mannschaft sofort besser macht. Hat sie damals noch in die Champions League geführt, die Roma. Ja, und jetzt ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen die Frage, wenn er kommt, welches System spielt, der als klassisches 4-3-3 gewohnt. Juve fehlt eigentlich der Rechtsverteidiger dafür. Da müsste er dann Campiaso nehmen, der alles spielen kann und dann im Winter vielleicht da auf der Position ein, zwei Ergänzungen holen. Aber ich glaube, man darf das nicht unterschätzen, dass Luciano Spalletti, wenn man sich jetzt vielleicht auch fragt, warum macht er das, das ist vielleicht seine letzte große Chance, auch da noch mal reinzukommen. Der hat damals bei Napoli gesagt, oh, jetzt ist ihm alles zu viel, er will ein Serbettical und dann ist er ja schnell zur Nationalmannschaft. Ich glaube, das ist auch das, was den Fans so ein bisschen übel aufgestoßen ist. Allerdings ist er auch ein Mann in dem Alter, Fußball-Business, wahrscheinlich hat er halt länger als drei Wochen zu Hause nicht ausgehalten. Also das ist so, da hat er sich vielleicht auch anders vorgestellt. Und dass er bei der Nationalmannschaft so krachend gescheitert ist, ist schon auch etwas, das ihm weh tut. Und in Italien, wenn er seinen Namen retten will, also die Meisterschaft von Napoli, über die denkt schon fast keiner mehr nach. Die haben alle nur in Erinnerung Nati an die Wand gefahren. Und jetzt ziehe ich mal den Vergleich. Hansi Flick, viel bei Bayern geholt, bei der Nati. Wir denken alle nur noch an die Graugänze. Und jetzt ist er bei Barca wieder. Also, wenn wir dann nächstes Jahr über den Luciano-Hansi Spalletti sprechen, wenn er Jubel wieder zur Meisterschaft geführt hat, dann habt ihr es hier zuerst gehört.
Sehr gut. Und gleichzeitig finde ich es auch ganz wunderbar, dass du ausgerechnet bei Juventus Turin dir als Notiz gemacht hast, Juve Lennon verscherbelt. Der hat jetzt ein bisschen Anlauf gebraucht, aber ich konnte ihn auch nicht liegen lassen, denn ich habe eine Bürgerpflicht zu erfüllen. Also, wir freuen uns auf Spalletti bei Juve und sind gespannt, wie es da weitergeht. Wir starten nochmal schnell in eine zweite Themenrunde. Nils, du bist wieder dran und du hast ein Thema mitgebracht, das haben sicherlich auch die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen. Es gab den Plan im Ausland ein La Liga-Spiel bzw. eigentlich zwei zu veranstalten. Dagegen haben aber unter anderem die Spieler protestiert mit 15 Sekunden Stillstand. Ist das richtig? Länger haben sie es nicht aushalten können als 15 Sekunden. Und das hat jetzt tatsächlich Erfolg gehabt. Wie ist denn das Ganze einzuordnen, deiner Meinung nach?
Ja, ist jetzt schon wieder eine Woche her. Es ging um ein Spiel wie Areal gegen Barcelona am 20. Dezember, das in Miami stattfinden sollte. Das ist so gesehen ein langjähriger Traum von Javier Tebas, dem Liga-Chef, der ja sehr viel Wert legt auf Vermarkt. Und Marketing und generell irgendwie das aufzublasen. Der hatte das schon mal 2021 versucht beim gleichen Spiel. Damals hatte das Luis Rubiales damals noch der Verbandspräsident verhindert. Mittlerweile ist mit Rafael Luzán ein Verbandspräsident da, der sich ganz gut mit Tebas versteht. Also hatte man schon das Gefühl, ah, da könnte jetzt wieder sowas, so ein Versuch gestartet werden, was dann jetzt seit August, glaube ich, angelaufen ist, wo die Vereine ihr Okay gegeben haben, wo auch eben der Verband RfEF sein Okay gegeben hat. Danach kam dann auch Dujeva mit dieser lustigen Mitteilung im Sinne von eigentlich nicht, aber widerwillig und ausnahmsweise, lassen wir das mal zu, dass Villarreal Barca Plus auch, ich glaube Milan Como in Australien stattfinden wird. Das waren die zwei. Ja, und dann gab es natürlich hier und da Proteststimmen aus Spanien. Das ist immer noch auf einem sehr, sehr geringen Niveau. Es ist nicht vergleichbar mit dem, was man bei in der Bundesliga gesehen hat gegen den DFL-Protest, Tennisbälle. Da gab es jetzt zum Beispiel keine großen Fanproteste in den Stadien. Hier und da hat sich natürlich mal ein Spieler geäußert, auch ein Hansi Flick, Frankie De Jong, also Beteiligte, sich da sehr kritisch zugeäußert. Und dann war es schlussendlich ein bisschen die Spieler-Gewerkschaft AFE, die sich da vor diesen Spieler-Protesten geäußert hat. Denen ging es aber auch mehr darum, dass fehlende Transparenz, fehlende Informationen. Sie haben Fragen gestellt im Sinne von, wie soll das für die Spieler sein, wie sollen die geschützt werden, noch mehr reisen und so weiter. Da gab es dann keine Antworten groß drauf. Also haben die Spieler-Gewerkschaft mit allen 20 Teams oder Teamkapitäninnen vereinbart, dass es da zu einer Protestaktion an diesem Wochenende kommen soll. Aber dieser Protest war nicht so spürbar. Einerseits, weil der Anstoß wurde ausgeführt, dann sind die Teams noch 10, 15, manchmal sogar 20 Sekunden stehen geblieben. Aber wenn da manche Spieler dehnen, kann man sich noch hüpfen, um warm zu bleiben. Also so ein richtiger Protest war das nicht plus on top. Unter anderem das erste Spiel war in Oviedo an dem Freitagabend. Da hat La Liga erst mal das TV-Bild rausgezogen aus dem Stadion. Man hatte nur die Außenfassade gesehen und dann auf einmal lief der Ball, als es dann wieder reingeblendet wurde. Also da ein bisschen Zensur plus, was hat La Liga danach, dann ab Samstag, Sonntag gemacht. Die haben dann teilweise gezeigt, wie die Spieler gestanden sind, haben aber einfach selbst so einen Spruch drüber geblendet, wie Committed to Peace. Also als wäre das ein Zeichen der Spieler für die Friedensverhandlungen in Biesreich.
Das habe ich noch gar nicht gehört. Das mit dem Reinschneiden in Stadion, das habe ich mitbekommen. Die haben einfach so getan, als wäre das eine Friedensaktion. Das ist ja weltklasse. Das öffnet ja Tür und Tor. Wenn es die nächste Proteste in der Bundesliga gibt, schreibt die DFL rein, Tennisbälle für den Frieden.
Genau, so ungefähr war das.
Das ist ja um Gottes Willen.
Eine echt dicke Nummer. Auch Thibaut Couture hat gesagt, das wundert ihn alles gar nicht mehr, wenn der Präsident sich ständig so peinlich auf Social Media selbst äußert, gegen alles schießt. Es geht ihm nur darum, La Liga primär zu vermarken, statt dass er irgendwie neue Technologien schaut. Es gibt immer noch keine Goal-Line-Technologie. Da gibt es eine lange Liste, was falsch läuft vielleicht in La Liga. Und jetzt diese Erstzensur plus dann noch. Das ist unsere Aktion, drüber zu blenden. Es war schon peinlich. Aber ich habe gesagt, der Protest war mir eigentlich ziemlich mau. Auch von den Fans hat man da nichts Großes gesehen. Aber wir haben jetzt auch nicht so eine Fan-Kultur wie in der Bundesliga vielleicht. Und trotzdem hat das dazu geführt, dass dieses Spiel jetzt doch noch gecancelt wurde vor einer Woche. Das aber auch mehr vom Veranstalter aus, weil der gespürt hat– oder La Liga hat da eine Mitteilung geschrieben– aufgrund der Unsicherheit, die in Spanien in den vergangenen Wochen aufgekommen ist, ist es gerade ein bisschen schwierig, da was zu planen. Wir reden ja auch über nur so zwei, drei Wochen, um erstmals ein La-Liga-Spiel auf einem anderen Kontinent oder außerhalb des Landes erstmals auszutragen. Da steckt ja auch logistisch einiges dahinter, was jetzt vielleicht zu kurzfristig war. Das war dem Veranstalter dann zu heiß und La Liga blieb da nichts mehr übrig, als zu sagen, ja gut, es ist jetzt erstmal wieder Fels aus. Aber das ist noch lange nicht durch im Sinne von, da wird es Ravi Theber in Zukunft sicher wieder probieren. Wie gesagt, das ist jetzt sein zweiter oder eher schon dritter Anlauf, das zu versuchen. Es ist sein großer Traum, sein Wunsch. Irgendwann wird er das kriegen und diese Büchse der Pandora endgültig öffnen, weil er jetzt auch schon von UEFA und auch von der FIFA die Zusage hatte. Aber da gab es dann auch noch mal vom Verband Conca-Cav Mittel-Nord-Amerika. Da gab es auch ein bisschen Gegenwind, weil die wollten, dass dann ein eigener Schiedsrichter von denen abgestellt wird. Also das war bestimmt eine Hürde, die hätte man auch noch schaffen können, wenn es wirklich jetzt darum ging, wenn der Veranstalter auch gesagt hat, ja, das ziehen wir jetzt durch. Ich glaube, Tickets wurden ja teilweise auch schon wieder für Vielstelliges verkauft in Miami. Also ja, das ist eine wilde Sache, aber schlussendlich gut für den Fußball, dass da nicht dieses eine Spiel mal ausnahmsweise stattfinden würde, weil man kann sich ja denken, dass es in Zukunft dann nicht bei nur einem Spiel pro Saison bleiben würde.
Also da könnte man jetzt ewig drüber diskutieren, auch weil man ja erkennen kann, dass Rabia Teba schon länger La Liga an US-Profiligen ausrichtet. Es gibt in der internationalen Vermarktung inzwischen einen Player, der zusammen mit CWC entwickelt wurde, der erinnert sehr an den NBA-Player, den es gibt von der Liga selbst und den MLB-Player, somit kleineren Elementen. Generell im Datenbereich hat man sich an der NBA ausgerichtet und da auch mit Augmented-Einblendungen von Daten da herum experimentiert. Und die International Games, die wir eben auch zum Beispiel von der NFL kennen, die wären dann ein logischer nächster Schritt, vielleicht auch ein Schritt, den La Liga tatsächlich geben muss, wenn man noch neue Märkte erschließen will. Aber man kann eben beides nicht genau miteinander gleichsetzen. Also die International Games in der NFL, die haben eine andere Historie und einen anderen Hintergrund, als es eben jetzt bei einem solchen La Liga International Game wäre. Deswegen ist die Diskussion dazu auch manchmal ein bisschen verkürzt, wenn das einfach miteinander direkt gleichgesetzt wird. Aber an der Stelle können wir das jetzt nicht weiter vertiefen, denn wir wollen ja auch noch mal in die anderen Ligen blicken. Unter anderem, Chris, noch mal in die Premier League. Was hast du uns denn da noch mitgebracht?
Ja, ich habe es schon angeteasert vorhin. FC Liverpool. Auch mit einem gewissen Hintergedanken. Ich habe mal nachgeschaut, am 18. September hatten wir in der Rasenfunk-Folge über den FC Liverpool gesprochen. Wir haben darüber geredet, ob man nach dem Transfer-Sommer und den vier Siegen in den ersten vier Spielen nicht mehr zu stoppen ist. Wir haben darüber geredet, dass nicht alles Gold ist, was glänzt. Seit diesem 18. September hat Liverpool sechs von sieben Pflichtspielen verloren. Und vier in Folge in der Premier League. Genauso viel wie im Vorjahr schon. Wie wir schon damals angeteasert haben, kommt das gar nicht so überraschend. Vielleicht in der Härte schon. Aber dass es einen kleinen Leistungsabfall gibt oder beziehungsweise eine geringere Ausbeute, das kommt gar nicht so überraschend. Aktuell ist das Problem. Leistungsträger performen nicht. Neuzergänge funktionieren nicht. Die Defensive ist löchrig. Die Außenverteidiger, die Neuen, Frimpong und Kerkes auf der anderen Seite offenbaren Schwächen. Konaté schwankt. Mittelfeld hat keine Spielkontrolle oder wenig. Es fehlt ein Defensivbewusstsein im Mittelfeld. Mosalak, ein Blatt von der Spur, wird noch nicht voll integriert auf seiner Wunschposition. Für Jügel spiele ich Existent. Also man merkt schon, da sind einige Baustellen. Und dazu merkt man auch im letzten Spiel eine gewisse Liturgie. Man merkt, dass da Frust eingekehrt ist und dass Liverpool mächtig zu kämpfen hat.
Spielt denn in der Betrachtung Liverpools dieses 5 zu 1 bei Eintracht Frankfurt gar keine Rolle? Also ist das nicht ein bisschen absurd, dass überall geschrieben wird, so jetzt haben sie schon wieder in Folge verloren. Man denkt so Moment, Entschuldigung, sie haben einmal gewonnen, aber offenbar.
Ich muss gestehen, ich habe während dem Eintrachtspiel, als Frankfurt das 1-0 gemacht hat, hatte ich noch ein Tweet abgefeuert im Sinne von, boah, dass Liverpool jetzt so schlecht wird, hätte ich jetzt echt nicht gedacht. Und dann ging es natürlich 5-1 aus. Also ich habe es gingenzt. Aber wenn man das Spiel gesehen hat, ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt nur die erste Halbzeit gesehen, das hätte auch anders ausgehen können. Also das hört sich jetzt bei einem 5-1 absurd an. Und wie gesagt, ich habe die zweite Hälfte nicht gesehen, habe gehört, dass Liverpool da deutlich stärker wurde. Aber nach der ersten Halbzeit, da hat Frankfurt genau das ausgenutzt, was Liverpool momentan nicht gut macht. Lange Bälle, Umschaltsituationen und so weiter. Und da war Liverpool sehr anfällig. Frankfurt hat dann auch ein paar Konter nicht gut zu Ende gespielt. Und die Tore von Liverpool waren ein Konter und eine Ecke.
Und das war jetzt auch kein spielerischer Offenbarungseid.
Also spielt nicht so eine große Rolle, weil man einfach auch sieht, wie groß die Probleme sind. Und weil diese Probleme jetzt einfach schon seit einer langen Zeit anhalten. Und wir haben eben über Arsenal gesprochen. Es fehlt auch eine Art und Weise, das Ganze zu kompensieren.
Unter anderem ist man jetzt ja auch mal wieder in einem Pokalwettbewerb gegen Flüster Palace ausgeschieden. Im EFL Cup natürlich da beide mit der zweiten Garde. Aber trotzdem natürlich summiert sich das mit dazu auf. Weil du jetzt schon so angesprochen hast, dass man auch schon so deutliche Frustanzeichen sieht bei Liverpool. Wie kritisch würdest du denn die Situation da sehen? Denn das klingt ja dann schon auch jenseits der Ergebnisse dramatischer, als man vielleicht hätte erwarten können nach dem Saisonstart.
Ja, vor allem macht mir so ein bisschen Gedanken, wie Arne Slot sich momentan in den Medien verkauft. Er wirkt ziemlich ratlos, wenn man das so sagen kann. Er verstrickt sich momentan in Ausreden. Das erinnert so ein bisschen an Ten Hake in den letzten Jahren, dass da immer irgendwas anderes schuld war, außer die eigene Leistung. Und ich hör jetzt hart an, aber er hat kritisiert, dass Mannschaften jetzt anders gegen Liverpool spielen, dass man jetzt darauf gar nicht vorbereitet war. Es gibt nämlich viele lange Bälle und da hat Liverpool Probleme. Er hat erwähnt, dass die Gegner mit anderen Aufstellungen spielen gegen Liverpool, als sie vermutet hatten. Also sind so Sachen, wo man denkt, ja, gehört halt dazu.
Da muss man sich auch ein bisschen anpassen.
Solche Dinge werden momentan kritisiert und ich finde, er macht das fast schon ein bisschen zu ehrlich, zu offen. Weil dann denkt man sich, ja, dann machen wir es dagegen. Du bist der Trainer, du musst ja irgendwie Anpassungen treffen, wenn du immer wieder die gleichen Gegentore kassierst oder die gleichen Schwachstellen hast. Und wenn man dann so offen und ehrlich damit umgeht, erwartet man noch mehr Resultate. Und nach dem Transfersommer mit 500 Millionen ist Druck da, keine Frage. Also da merkt man momentan, Slot spürt den Druck. Und das war letztes Jahr so noch so eine Sache, dass Liverpool nie wirklich ernst Druck spürte, weil Liverpool, weil Arsenal City waren einfach nicht gut, hatten solchen Jahre, haben Liverpool nie wirklich gechallenged. Das war eigentlich Walk in the Park sozusagen, wie Liverpool den Titel am Ende geholt hat. Das soll überhaupt nicht den Titel mindern oder sonst was. Aber es waren dankbare Umstände am Ende und jetzt zum ersten Mal mit diesem Transfer, mit diesem Saisonstart kommt jetzt zum ersten Mal richtig Druck rein und man merkt, dass Slot sich da noch ein bisschen mit schwer tut.
Mario, du wolltest noch was sagen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht. Ich wollte mal nur Chris fragen, inwiefern das auch noch Thema ist, auch in den englischen Medien oder für dich selber auch, das mit Yoko Shota. Also ich kann mir jetzt auch sagen, ja, hat man schon vergessen, es ist schon wieder fast ein halbes Jahr her, aber ich finde, na gut, klar, da kommen dann auch neue dazu, aber die kommen dann in eine Kabine, in der die Stimmung wahrscheinlich nicht mehr so sein wird, wie sie dann in der letzten Saison war. Ich kann mir halt immer schwer vorstellen, dass das einfach irgendwie abgelegt wird und dann funktionieren wieder alle so wie davor.
Ja, keine Frage. Also am Anfang wurde schon mehr darüber geredet. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen in den Hintergrund gerückt. Und ich würde mir jetzt auch nicht persönlich jetzt irgendwie anmaßen, das zu beurteilen, wie ein Spieler damit umgeht oder nicht. Wir wissen es nicht, was für ein Effekt das in der Kabine hat. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es auf jeden Fall schwer war für die gesamte Mannschaft.
Das ist gar keine Frage.
Ich versuche mich halt bei der Analyse immer so ein bisschen an das zu orientieren, was ich beurteilen kann. Und die Probleme, die ich jetzt nannte, die nenne ich selbstbewusst, sage ich mal, weil man da schon Ansätze letztes Jahr gesehen hat vor dieser Tragödie, die einen emotionalen Impact hat. Und dieses Defensive-Umschall-Spiel, wackelende Defensive etc., die waren schon letztes Jahr da. Und deswegen haben wir ja auch in der letzten Folge im September drüber geredet, ob dieses Transferfenster so schillernd und glänzend es war, ob es wirklich so sinnvoll war, weil man einfach eine Stimme für 100 Millionen geholt hat, Probleme auf der Sechs hat, Probleme in der Verteidigung hat. Ja, dann holen wir noch eine Stimme für 150 Millionen. Und das sind so die Sachen, die man merkt. Aber ja, keine Frage, dass die Jota-Thematik, die Tragödie, die wird durchaus irgendwo eine Rolle spielen.
Es geht jetzt anspruchsvoll weiter. Heimspiel gegen Asken Villa, die sind aktuell punktgleich mit Liverpool. Heimspiel gegen Real Madrid und dann Auswärtsspiel bei Manchester City. Also das wird jetzt alles innerhalb von neun Tagen im November. Da wird sich so manche Weiche schon stellen. Wir werden es weiter natürlich genau im Blick behalten und gucken nochmal in die Niederlande. Daniel, worüber magst du noch mit uns sprechen?
Ja, so ein bisschen über Ajax nochmal, leider, muss man schon sagen. Ich hab so ein bisschen in den letzten Tagen die Analogie bemüht. Ajax ist so ein bisschen wie so ein Rätselheft am Bahnhof. So ein Sudoku, aber so ein Killer-Sudoku und irgendwie achtmal die Faktorzahl einträgt und wieder ausradiert. Weil ich werde auch nicht mehr langsam schlau aus dieser Mannschaft. Sie sind ja in der aktuellen Saison generell nicht so gut reingekommen. Jetzt nicht schlecht, immer noch auf Platz 4. Es ist okay. Es ist nicht der Anspruch natürlich, aber es ist okay. Es hat mit verschiedenen kleinen Sachen zu tun, die siehst du mir an. Das sind Transfers, da ist Hatto für 60 Millionen, glaube ich, weggebrochen. So Chelsea, da ist Probe im Sturm weggebrochen. Du hast viele Neuzugänge, die dich noch ein bisschen integrieren müssen. Klauk in der Offensive oder Hita Kura aus Lappbach gekommen. Du hast eben den neuen Trainer, da komme ich auch gleich noch mal drauf, auf den Heitinga. Es ist noch ein Mittelumbruch, nicht kleiner, auch kein riesiger, aber schon nennenswerter. Das führt dann eben dazu, dass du hier und da ein paar Punkte gegenlässt, auch gegen kleinere Mannschaften. Und dass die Taktik von Heitinga, der dieses Frioli-System ein bisschen angepasst hat, nicht mehr so stark offensiv spielen lässt, braucht noch ein bisschen Abstimmung. Das hat dazu geführt, dass man Punkte hier und da liegen gelassen hat, und mittlerweile auch den Trainer sehr staketisiert, weil er sich auch vercoacht hat, als ein oder andere Mal. In der letzten Folge des Rasenfunks, wo ich auch dabei war, gab es ja das Spiel in der Champions League gegen Marseille. Da hatten wir ja damals auch darüber gesprochen. Da hat er einmal gesagt, wir wollen offensiv draufgehen, wir wollten auf Preston das Flugheben damit ansagen, um die Ohren. Und jetzt haben sie gegen Chelsea in der Champions League wieder verloren. Und das war interessant, denn die ersten 10, 20 Minuten sah es eigentlich gut aus. Dann gab es eine rote Karte für Taylor von Ajax. Dann war es ein 5-1. Also dann, ja, lief es im Bach runter. Wobei aber man sagen muss, dass es bis dahin echt okay war, dass sie wirklich mal Ballbesitzphasen hatten, das konstruiert gespielt haben, jetzt nicht dominiert haben. Aber schon, wenn man sagen könnte, ey, wenn das so weitergeht, wenn sie das auch rechterhalten können, ist vielleicht ein Punkt drin. So war der Eindruck von diesem Champions-League-Spiel. Weil Heitinga auch ein bisschen überrascht hat. Er hat lange an seinem Team festgehalten, an der Startelf, und hat dann vor Chelsea relativ überraschend den Torwart gewechselt. Also hat Jarosz rausgenommen für den ewigen Passfär, der dann mal wieder spielt. Eigentlich auch eher so halb ohne Not. Also Jarosz war jetzt eigentlich relativ solide. Er hatte hier und da mal einen Wackeler, okay. Aber er würde für mich jetzt eigentlich nicht ausreichen, um zu rechtfertigen, wir müssen den jetzt von dem relativ wichtigen Champions-League-Spiel austauschen. Die ersten beiden Ligen verloren. Das heißt, klar, auch wenn der Name Chelsea relativ großer ist. Die läuft ja auch nicht alles rund bei denen. Da hätte man schon vielleicht sagen können, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht noch eine Torwart-Thematik. Na gut, war trotzdem aufgemacht. Dann wurde McConnel im Mittelfeld aufgestellt, das Startelf-Debüt gewesen für ihn. Also sehr viele Veränderungen in der Startelf. Ich war eher skeptisch, hat aber gut funktioniert bis zur Roten Karte. Und dann hast du gemerkt, da war die Hoffnung auch weg. Und da wurden die Beine irgendwann müde, was ich verstehen kann. Und dann stand Heitinga mit anderthalb Beinen schon vorm Rauswurf. Also medial, die nigerländischen Medien sind ja auch noch ein bisschen dreister und ein bisschen härter, was das angeht. Da wurde er ja eigentlich schon gefühlt, ach mal entlassen. Er hat sich aber noch gehalten, aus verschiedenen Gründen, die ich auch gleich nochmal kurz anreise. Und dann kommt dieses Rätselheftspiel gegen Twente Endsrede jetzt am Samstag, wo sie zur Haltzeit völlig verliebt nur zu einem Zurückliegen, Zurücklagen. Die haben auch dieselben Stadtwerfe genommen wie gegen Chelsea, weil man bis zur roten Karte dachte, es hat funktioniert. Und war man überhaupt nicht präsent, es hat eigentlich nichts funktioniert von dem, was Heitinga spielen lassen will. Und dann kamen sieben Minuten und drei Tore für Ajax. Und ich weiß nicht, woher diese sieben Minuten gekommen sind, in denen quasi fast alles funktioniert hat. In diesen sieben Minuten hast du mal gesehen, wie Heitinga Kurzpass spielen lassen will und wie es aussehen kann. Er möchte im Mittelfeld immer gerne ein bisschen überladen, zieht dann auch gerne mal einen Verteidiger noch rein, will irgendwie Räume schaffen, penkt die Flügelspieler-Szene. Es hat alles wunderbar funktioniert. Die waren passsicher, da war Einsatz drin. Plus noch individuelle Klasse von Klauch im Mittelfeld, von Wechhorst und auch von dem Talent Mika Horst. Das hat alles gut funktioniert. und die 3. stürzten auch. Und nach diesen 7 Minuten war es wieder vorbei. Dann war irgendwie wieder Rumpelfußball. Dann haben sie das 3-2 noch kassiert. Sie haben dann den Sieg mit Acher und Kraft über ihr Zeitgerät gerettet. Und ich werde nicht schlafen, was in diesen 7 Minuten passiert ist. Wenn wir diese 7 Minuten, wenn diese Spielanlage und das mal ausgedehnt werden würde auf einen längeren Zeitraum, dann würden wir auch von einem ganz anderen Ajax reden. Und da sieht man eigentlich, dass die Qualität im Kader schon da ist, trotz der tollen Verkäufe. Aber irgendwie haben sie es nicht geschafft, diese Phase bislang häufiger zu zeigen.
Aber kann Ajax aus diesem, wir feuern ein Trainer nach dem anderen, im Grunde seit, also man hat einen Tenhaktrauma, anders als Lirakusen. Aber seitdem ist es ja so, dass immer wieder, und das haben wir jetzt auch in den letzten Ligaturen immer wieder besprochen, kein Trainer darf eine ganze Saison machen oder selten mal eine komplette Saison. Und so richtig zufrieden ist man eigentlich nie. Kann man aus diesem Zirkel wirklich ausbrechen, indem man jetzt einfach nochmal einen neuen Trainer holt? Weil Heitinga war ja schon mal erfolgreich Trainer und er kommt aus der Jugend. Er hat natürlich auch eine Historie mit diesem Verein. Es ist allerdings, wenn ich es jetzt richtig gesehen habe, seine erste Station als Chef-Trainer. Das heißt, gewisse Anpassungsproblematiken muss man ja eigentlich auch eingepreist haben, wenn du so jemanden dir als Trainer holst.
Ja, also das Ding ist hinter vorgehaltener Hand. Es ist halt schon so, dass vor allem der Kostenfaktor auch mit Aufschlag geben war für Heitinga. Also es gab auch schon die Überlegung größeren Namen richtig zu holen. Aber andererseits wollten vielleicht auch die nicht so. Das ist die andere Wahrheit. Und eben der andere Faktor ist der Kostenfaktor. Und das ist auch, so hört man, wohl der Grund, warum Heitinga auch noch Trainer ist. Es hatte sich jetzt der technische Direktor Alex Cruz, der ist seit 2024 da. Kurz wie meint er, dass es der, der eben Anfang 2024 begonnen hat bei Ajax, damals doch als CEO, und wurde nach zwei Wochen beurlaubt aufgrund von Insider-Handel. Da hat er sich kurz vor seiner Berufung irgendwie ein paar hundert Aktien von Ajax noch gegönnt. Und nachdem dann dieses Thematik bisschen zugekommen ist, durfte er wieder zurückkehren und ist bis heute im Amt. Und der hat Heitinga geholt, damals ja von Liverpool, war ja Co-Unterslot. Und hatte jetzt vor, doch kurz vor dem Spiel gegen Chelsea, in einem Fanmagazin, in Ajax live, das ist so semi-professionell, also jetzt nicht nur ein Fanmagazin, aber schon mit 3 Tagen seiner Arbeit, aber jetzt kein klassisches Medium. Da hat er sich hingesetzt, eine Stunde in Podcast und hat so ein bisschen geplaudert. Und meinte auch dann, ja, wenn Heitinga geht, gehe ich mit, also er hat sein eigenes Sticksal gekoppelt an den Trainer, was für Ajax eigentlich letztendlich heißt, wir müssen zwei Leute neu ersetzen und zwei Leute weiter bezahlen. Und das ist bei Ajax schon ein großes Thema für die finanzielle Lage. Deswegen haben sie ja auch diese teuren Verkäufe letztendlich auch dann dann tätigt mit mit Hardtun und Propel und für weniger Geld eingekauft. Und das ist einfach ein Grund mit, warum der Hatinga noch Trainer ist, weil es einfach zu teuer wäre und man sich nicht leisten könnte. Ich halte es auch sportlich durchaus für sinnvoll, Hatinga eben jetzt nicht auch noch rauszuschmeißen, weil klar, wenn du diese hohe Fluktuation beibehältst, dann kann ja auch nichts letztendlich Gepästes bei rumkommen, weil dann hast du einen neuen Trainer, vielleicht einen neuen Spiel-Idee, dann wird das System wieder geändert, dann brauchst du wieder eine Anpassungsphase, ein bisschen schlimmes Hittenspieltag. Das ist auch bei entscheidender Phase, da ist ein 6-Punkte-Rückstand auf 1 und 2. Also wenn man jetzt noch einen neuen Trainer mit einer neuen Idee holen würde, der ja auch wieder irgendwie 10 Spieltage braucht, dann müsste er im Endeffekt auf 6 oder 7. Und dann muss er am Ende noch zusehen, dass du in die EL vielleicht noch kommst, was finanziell auch wichtig wäre, wenn du in die CL kommst und so weiter und so fort.
Ja, total. Vor allem, also müssen wir jetzt nicht noch weiter diskutieren, aber was man halt nicht aus dem Blick verlieren darf, wir argumentieren das immer vom einzelnen Verein aus und sehen dann eigentlich müsste Ajax besser sein und eigentlich braucht es doch nur zwei, drei Spieler und einen richtigen Trainer. Und dann müsste man doch eigentlich, und was aber in diesem eigentlich dann oft vergessen wird, ist, es gibt ja einen Wettbewerb. Und bei einem Wettbewerb muss man eben einfach sagen, PSV und Feyenoord, die haben Schritte gemacht in den letzten Jahren. Das haben wir ja auch hier immer wieder diskutiert. Das heißt, uneigentlich kann es sein, dass du mit einem anderen Trainer vielleicht leichte Fortritte machst und es trotzdem noch nicht reicht, weil die anderen sind nicht stehen geblieben in den letzten Jahren.
Ja, also ich glaube, Ziel für Ajax ist nicht Meister zu werden. Zumindest nicht in dieser Saison, vielleicht auch in der nächsten, sondern sich mal wirklich solide zu entwickeln, dass man vielleicht in der Tapest League nicht solche Klatschen bekommt, nicht so derbe Klatschen bekommt, dass man auch in der Liga gegen die kleineren Vereine mal Lösungen findet. Das ist dann klar, wenn sie sich da reinstellen, du dann auch unterhalb der Dinge auch schon merkst, so die wirklichen kreativen Ideen kommen da jetzt auch noch nicht. Dass du eben da diese Konzernz hast, weil das ist ja das, was PSV und Ferien Nord in den letzten Jahren geschafft haben. Peter Bosz ist ja auch schon jetzt relativ lange da und auch bei Ferien Nord mit Arno Slott hat er gut gearbeitet. Van Persie setzt die Arbeit da gut vor mit einer ähnlichen Idee. Also das passt auch. Da wurden auch Trainer so gegauchte, gegausht, dass sie zum Verein und zur Idee auch passen bei beiden. Und bei Ergst hat man das im letzten Jahr nicht so sagen. Da wurde dann auf andere Faktoren eher geachtet, wie eben Preis, Verfügbarkeit und vielleicht auch Namen oder Vereinsgeruch, Stahlgeruch. Das sind dann andere Faktoren, die da vielleicht den Aufschlag gegeben haben, auf die man vielleicht nicht vordergründig achten sollte. Aber ich hoffe einfach mal, dass diese sieben Minuten ausgeweilt werden können in den nächsten Wochen. Das würde mich einfach auch freuen.
Das ist ein wunderschöner, wunderschöner Buch.
Ich wollte nur eine Sache dazu sagen. Klar, kleine Samplesize, aber ich habe jetzt zum Beispiel mal Wout Wichors über insgesamt vielleicht vier Halbzeiten auch in der Länderspielpause bei der Nahti gesehen. Ich glaube, Limit ist erreicht bei ihm auch.
Du hast halt keinen Stürmer, das ist ja die Krux. Du hast Caspar Dolberg, der aber verletzt ist. Du hast mit Frobbe einen klaren Nummer neun verkauft. Und Heitinka spielt eben in diesen 4-2-3-1 aktuell mit einer Spitze. Da ist nur eine Spitze. Die anderen sind eigentlich eher Flügelspieler oder offensive Mittelfeldspieler oder auf jeden Fall nicht wirklich Durststürmer. Wobei, ich muss sagen, jetzt gegen Twente war er gut. Hat ihm gut gefallen. Aber klar, es ist keine 1A-Lösung, sage ich mal.
Also in den sieben Minuten von Angel, der hatte ja jeder gefallen. Das haben wir ja gestern schon rausgesucht.
Ja, das sowieso. Aber in den sieben Minuten waren alle top. Nur bei Bechorz ist halt das Problem, dass er auch konkurrenzlos ist bei Arags im Sturm. Da ist halt auch sonst niemand, der ihm da wirklich gefährlich werden könnte. Höchstens Dolberg, aber der ist eben noch geletzt.
Ja, also wir werden es im Blick behalten und mal gucken, wie sich Ajax da entscheidet. Und als du von Klatschen gesprochen hast, die man vermeiden wollte, da musste ich direkt an Jakob denken, also beziehungsweise an sein Thema natürlich, nicht an Jakob persönlich. Denn du willst mit uns noch über den FC Metz sprechen, Jakob. Der ursprünglich noch keinen Sieg hatte nach neun Spieltagen, aber jetzt, gestern war es, hat es tatsächlich mal geklappt. Gestern gab es ein 2 zu 0 gegen Lens, bedeutet aber trotzdem weiter letzter Platz, aber immerhin jetzt fünf Punkte und nicht mehr so komplett aussichtslos wie Anfang dieser Woche. Was ist denn da los bei Metz?
Ja, was ist los bei Metz? Also, ich glaube auch, hätten wir die Sendung jetzt nicht heute aufgenommen, sondern vielleicht gestern Morgen hätte man sicherlich noch drastischer über Metz gesprochen. Jetzt sind ja, glaube ich, dann die Wolves das einzige Team in den Top-5-Ligen noch ohne Sieg. Und da hat Metz sich jetzt also wirklich befreit und tatsächlich auch sehr beeindruckend gestern. Also, sie hatten, glaube ich, auch einen XG-Wert von über 3 in dem Spiel. Also, sie haben zwar die Tore erst in der 87. und in der Nachspielzeit gemacht, aber es war auch wirklich hoch verdient. Und das ja auch gegen Lens, über die wir wahrscheinlich gleich auch noch kurz sprechen, die ja auch durchaus ein gutes Team sind. Also, jetzt auch nicht gegen den Abstiegskonkurrenten, sondern schon eine beeindruckende Leistung. Aber man kann das jetzt natürlich nicht sagen, okay, jetzt ist alles wieder super, weil du hast es angesprochen vorher, zwei Punkte aus neun Spielen nur sieben Mal verloren. Man hatte den schlechtesten Sturm, hat die schlechteste Abwehr der Liga. Also, es sieht eigentlich alles nicht gut aus und man konnte das auch vor der Saison schon so ein bisschen ahnen. Also, man ist auch nur über die Relegation hochgekommen, ist also sozusagen auch schon rein nominell der schlechteste der drei Aufsteiger gewesen. Dazu kommt ja, dass bei den anderen beiden Aufsteigern, also Paris FC, haben ja wahrscheinlich viele mitbekommen. Die haben ja finanziell ganz andere Möglichkeiten. Bei Lorient war es so, dass die halt einfach auch in der letzten Saison schon deutlich besser waren, deutlich mehr Punkte geholt haben. Und ja, jetzt in dieser Saison lief auch in einigen Spielen ein bisschen was für die, aber über die wollen wir ja gar nicht sprechen, sondern über Metz. Und der Kader ist schon jetzt nicht so sonderlich gut, muss man sagen. Also, sie haben auch noch ein paar Leistungsträger verloren. Da muss man vor allem auch Udol nennen, der jetzt auch bei Lens tatsächlich spielt auf der gestrigen Gegenseite. Also, der war in der letzten Saison Kapitän, ist ein Verteidiger, hat aber, meine ich, auch sechs oder sieben Tore geschossen, hat auch in der Relegation getroffen. Also, wirklich so eigentlich einer der wichtigsten Spieler. Die beiden Topscorer aus der letzten Saison Gauthier Hain und Sheikh Sabali haben jetzt in dieser Saison, abgesehen von gestern im Falle von Hain, noch gar nicht wirklich funktioniert. Gerade bei Gauthier Hain, der ist jetzt auch schon 29. Und bei dem muss man auch sagen, dass der so ein klassischer– ja, ich bin in der zweiten Liga einer der besten, aber in der ersten Liga klappt es nicht so richtig. Spieler ist bisher gewesen, zumindest immer. Und ob sich das jetzt in dieser Saison ändert, muss man mal schauen. Die ersten neun Spieltage haben eher darauf hingedeutet, nicht unbedingt. Gestern hat er dann das 1-0 gemacht und auch das 2-0 hat dann sich danach das Trikot ausgezogen und ist noch mit gelb-rot vom Platz geflogen. Also auch eine sehr clevere Aktion. Ugo Ikitike lässt grüßen. Und ja, aber er kann halt, wenn er gut in Form ist, schon so der Faktor sein für Metz, weil er schon ein sehr spielstarker Offensivspieler ist. Ganz klein gewachsen, also körperlich auch, wahrscheinlich nicht unbedingt auf dem Level, aber ist schon eigentlich ein ganz cooler Spieler. Und man hat dann dazu auch noch ein paar Neuzugänge geholt, die jetzt aber auch noch nicht so richtig eingeschlagen haben. Also im Sturm hat man mit Abib Diallo eingeholt, der hat in der Ligue 1 schon mal ganz gut performt, hat aber davor jetzt bei Al-Shabab gespielt und funktioniert jetzt auch bisher noch nicht gut in dieser Saison. Und ansonsten ist der Kader halt auch, ja, dann doch eher ein Zweitligakader als ein Ligue 1-Kader. Man hat zwar auch ein paar bekannte Spieler mit Jean-Philippe Géberman und Benjamin Stambouli, also zwei alte Bekannte aus der Bundesliga. Die Betonung liegt gerade bei Stambouli natürlich aber auch auf alt. Also, der ist jetzt auch schon 35. Er hat zum Beispiel am Wochenende auch gegen Lille nicht gut ausgesehen, Géberman aber auch nicht, wo sie ja 6 zu 1 verloren haben, auch sehr, sehr deutlich. Und bei Géberman muss man auch dazu sagen, der war ja auch wirklich in den letzten Jahren wirklich nur verletzt. Und da ist es überhaupt überraschend, dass er jetzt tatsächlich in den letzten Wochen zumindest mal wieder ein bisschen konstanter auch spielen kann. Der ist aber auch weit von seinem Mainz-Niveau momentan noch entfernt. Und grundsätzlich, ja, es ist schwer zu sagen, wie es bei Metz jetzt weitergeht. Ich meine, es kann natürlich sein, dass sie jetzt wirklich so das Gefühl haben, okay, wir sind jetzt angekommen und können uns jetzt wirklich zusammenreißen oder finden jetzt irgendwie was, was uns so richtig ausmacht. Weil das konnte ich jetzt zumindest in dieser Saison auch noch nicht so richtig identifizieren, was sie überhaupt wollen. Also wollen sie jetzt defensiv ganz kompakt stehen und dann auf Konter spielen, wenn das so sein sollte. Das sah zumindest gegen Lille so aus, da hat es aber halt überhaupt nicht funktioniert, weil sie die Bälle viel zu schnell verloren haben oder immer nur blind nach vorne gekloppt haben. Dementsprechend müssen sie da vielleicht so ein bisschen ihre Art und Weise finden, wie man denn dann überhaupt punkten kann. Das liegt dann natürlich auch so ein bisschen an Trainer Stefan Le Mignon, der jetzt aber auch auf dem Niveau, ehrlich gesagt, noch gar keine Erfahrung hat, ist im letzten Sommer, also ist mit ihnen aufgestiegen, hat davor aber nur bei kleineren Clubs trainiert, also Concano, Créteil, Boulogne und Wann waren seine Stationen davor, ist jetzt auch nicht mehr ein absolutes Talent mit 51. Aber ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass im Verein auch das relativ realistisch bisher noch betrachtet wird, was einfach die Ausgangslage ist. Und da war jetzt auch nicht sonderlich Alarm. Man hat jetzt noch nicht so viel gehört, dass Le Mignon so großartig unter Druck wäre. Und ich weiß auch nicht, inwiefern sich das jetzt ändert, wenn man zumindest jetzt so ein bisschen ab und zu mal auch punktet. Aber ich glaube, es ist schon nicht unwahrscheinlich, dass man wieder absteigt. Es ist in den letzten Jahren auch immer so gewesen, dass man hoch und runter gebounst ist. So ein bisschen, also Metz, der JuJu-Club schlechthin in den letzten– also in diesem Jahrtausend eigentlich waren teilweise auch in der dritten Liga und sind aber halt zumindest zwischen der zweiten und ersten Liga eigentlich relativ konstant immer hin und her. Und wenn sie mal ein Jahr den Klassen erhalt schaffen, steigen sie eigentlich im nächsten auch wieder ab.
Also so ganz überraschend ist es nicht. Aber um jetzt die Ehre von Metz zu retten, man war bei Weitem nicht das einzige Team, das gemeinsam mit den Wolfen noch sieglos war in der Liga. Wir haben in der Serie A Verona, Pisa, Florenz und Genua, die noch nicht gewonnen haben. Und dann schauen wir mal in die Bundesliga. Grüße nach Gladbach. Stimmt. Also ganz so schlimm ist es dann doch nicht.
Wo ich das gerade hergezogen habe, weiß ich auch nicht genau.
Ich war noch kurz überrascht und bei Gladbach war ich mir sicher und dann habe ich hier nochmal kurz durchgeklickt. Also das ist ja auch nicht ganz so überraschend. Aber wir wollen auch nochmal in die Serie A blicken. Da jetzt allerdings dann auch auf einen europäischen Vergleich. Denn es gibt noch ein Team, das in Europas Ligen ungeschlagen ist. Eins ist der FC Bayern und das zweite Mario ist Trommelwirbel.
Alain de Bergamo.
So nämlich.
Und sonst bin ich ja gerne auch mal dafür bekannt, dass ich auf die Trainer drauf haue und Christian Bernhardt immer den Advokaten spielt mit den positiven Aspekten. Und ehrlicherweise will ich das diese Woche gerne übernehmen. Ivan Juric hat auch in diesem Podcast, glaube ich, von der einen oder anderen Seite auch aus England, schon auf den Deckel bekommen und auch zurecht. Und wenn man sich das dann aber nochmal das große Bild zeichnet, ist eigentlich nur ein Jahr richtig schlecht gewesen bei Ivan Juric. Das war die Zeit bei der Roma. Er ist ein schwieriger Charakter und da wurde auch, glaube ich, aus Spielerkreisen nicht gut über ihn geredet. Allerdings waren das teilweise auch Spieler, bei denen immer die Trainer schuld sind. Man muss sagen, er hat bei Atalanta ein großes Erbe angetreten, mit Gian Piero Gasperini. Er ist auch ein Gasperini-Schüler, klar, das hat alles Sinn gemacht. Darüber, glaube ich, hat man schon einiges gelesen. Ich war auch trotzdem kritisch und dachte, kann das funktionieren? Und man muss sagen, es funktioniert spielerisch sehr gut. Einzig, sie machen die Tore noch nicht. Also dieses große Offensivfeuerwerk ist nicht da. Und wenn man sich nur die Ergebnisse der letzten Wochen anschaut, könnte man meinen, von außen betrachtet, ach guck mal, ja hier, klar, Ivan Juric ist da, jetzt spielen die immer nur 0-0 und 1-1. Ich habe mir nochmal die Mühe gemacht, mir eine XG-Tabelle anzugucken und auch Expected Points, da wären sie auf Platz 3 hinter Inter und Milan. Also sie haben auch in vielen Partien, klar, auch gegen Aufsteiger Cremonese, wo Jamie Wadi getroffen hat, im Übrigen zum ersten Mal, und der dann mit dem der Name hier mal getroppt wurde. Es gab mindestens zwei Spiele, wo man safe hätte, einfach zwei Punkte mehr mitnehmen müssen, dann würde alles ganz anders aussehen. Aber ich sehe bei der Mannschaft ganz viele positiven Aspekte. Lukeman hat es wieder getroffen gegen Milan, da gab es im Sommer das Ding, dass er sich wegstreiken wollte. Und dann hat Atalanta Stärke bewiesen, hat gemeint, nee, ist nicht genug, was Inter zahlt. Du bleibst hier, auch wenn du nicht trainierst. Dadurch hat er natürlich die ganze Saisonvorbereitung nicht mitgemacht. Aber das finde ich zum einen, war Atalanta schon immer konsequent bei sowas. Und dann auch noch diese Größe zu haben, zu sagen, okay, aber jetzt du willst wieder, dann spiel, integriere dich. Und er spielt, hat jetzt wieder getroffen. Klar, ihnen geht halt auch mit Retegi der Top-Torjäger der letzten Saison ab. Oscar Maka war mit einem Kreuz bei Dresden ganzes Jahr raus. Aber ansonsten sind da auch schon wieder ganz viele spannende Namen. Ihr könnt euch mal gerne Ahanor aufschreiben. Das ist ein 17-jähriger Junge in Italien geboren, nigerianische Eltern, spielt Dreierkette, als würde er schon zwei, drei Jahre Profi-Fußball spielen. Und alles, was es unter Gasperini auch gab, mit dieser Intensität durchverteidigen, die IVs-Rücken, das hatten wir jetzt gegen Milan. Da hat sich dann mal Rafa Leo, der Cheminist, tief bis in die eigene Hälfte fallen lassen, um sich Bälle abzuholen. Und Ahanor und Hiren, die Innenverteidiger, verfolgen die bis 30 Meter vor ihrem eigenen Tor. Also da ist ganz, ganz viel Spannendes mit dabei. Und wenn da dann der Knoten offensiv gesehen platzt, dann haben sie auch mit Charles de Quetelar immer noch einen, der auch nicht das Fußballspielen verlernt hat, freue ich mich sehr drauf. Bin selbst etwas überrascht, dass das so gut funktioniert, auch wenn es man in der faktischen Tabelle so vielleicht noch nicht wieder sieht, aber in den nächsten paar Wochen, Ende November, bin ich in Frankfurt im Stadion, da spielen sie bei der Eintracht, freue ich mich sehr drauf. Und wenn sich die Entwicklung so weiterzieht, dann glaube ich, muss die SGE sich da auf was gefasst machen.
Ja, es wird ja ein 5-1 in die eine oder die andere Richtung. So. Da kann man sich gerade...
Als erstes jetzt natürlich müssen sie erst mal noch nach Napoli, die Eintracht. Vielleicht gibt es da auch ein 5-1, auch ohne Kevin de Bruyne. Das habe ich ohne dass es gewerkt, dass mein drittes Thema untergebracht. Nein, aber das ist, wenn ich gerade drüber nachgedacht habe, nur dass ich es mal gehört habe, es ist so ein großes Thema, ist es natürlich auch gar nicht. Weil es schnell zu Ende erzählt ist, Kevin de Bruyne hat sich am Wochenende beim Elfmeterschießen den Oberschenkel zerschossen und ja, dachte es zum Muskelfaseriss, Muskelbündelriss. Na gut, dann sind es halt bei dem alten Mann vielleicht mal sechs Wochen, statt irgendwie wie bei dem 21-jährigen drei. Es ist so viel kaputtgegangen in diesem Oberschenkel, musste operiert werden, ist schon wieder in der belgischen Heimat, fällt vermutlich bis Februar aus. Das ist schon krass und extrem bitter.
Aber wie lange hat der vorher gespielt? Der wurde ja nicht eingewechselt vor diesem Elfmeterschießen.
Nee, das war ein Elfmeter im Spiel, erste Halbzeit.
Ach so, okay, alles klar. Ach so, bei einem Elfmeter. Ich dachte, das war ja gar kein Pokal. Ich war schon völlig verrückt. Ja, okay, ja, interessant. Ich meine, es gibt Trainer, die deswegen das auf das Tor schießen am Ende des Trainings verbieten bei ihren Spielerinnen und Spielern, weil das eine typische Bewegung ist, bei der noch mal eine Verletzung passiert. Also so hat Alex Pop zum Beispiel das EM-Finale verpasst. Vor drei Jahren ist es inzwischen her. Wenn du allerdings im Spiel schießt, ja, okay, da war schon... Also Kevin de Bruyne wird nicht mit dabei sein, das haben wir ja mitbekommen, aber dass es so übel ist, ehrlich gesagt, noch nicht. Danke dafür. Wir machen noch einen ganz schnellen Rundumschlag. Daniel, du hast uns noch was aus der Eredivise mitgebracht.
Genau, eine kleine Nachliste zum Topper, zur Fair Yard Road gegen PSV am Sonntag. War ein sehr spannendes und unterhaltsamen Spiel. Dauerte ein bisschen länger, ging nämlich 15, 20 Minuten später los. Es gab eine sehr, sehr große Choreo von Fair Yard Road mit sehr, sehr vielen Papierschnipseln. Es war auch sehr windig leider. Das heißt, die ganzen Schnipsel haben dann auf dem Spielfeld gelegen, haben die Linien blockiert, dann kamen auch die…
Wenn Major Rieke immer noch grinst, wenn eine Papierkugel auch nur angedeutet wird, das ist ja umflachlich.
Da wird rochennal. Wir erinnern uns. Aber das war jetzt so flacher Schnipsel-Air, also keine Gefahr, dass da Ecken resultieren. Jedenfalls kamen irgendwann die Laubbläsertruppe, die dann versucht hat, gegen den Wind zu arbeiten, der von außen kommt. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Dann kamen irgendwann die Rechenschieber. Und irgendwann hatte man dann die Linien frei, und dann konnte es auch losgehen. Und es hat Paysway gewonnen mit 32. Es war ein sehr unterhaltsames Spiel. Das war das erwartete Spiel von Platz 1 gegen Platz 2. Ein paar Sachen waren schon auffällig. Einmal hat Robin van Persie in die Trickkiste gegriffen bei Feyenoord und Sam Steyn, eigentlich den Topspieler dieses Teams, auf der Bank schmoren lassen. Bis tief in die 80. Minute rein, was sehr ungewöhnlich war. Aber davor war er Stammspieler. War jetzt auch nicht in einem Formtief oder so. Und er hat es dann nachbegründet. Sie wollten etwas Taktisches ausprobieren. Hat dann nicht ganz genau gesagt, was. Vermutlich, weil es nicht funktioniert hat. Es war der Gedanke, der sich aufdrängte, dass man wirklich ein bisschen defensiver agieren wollte, im Mittelfeld ein bisschen mehr Krib haben will. Dann kam Valente, Führst du in die Semmstrasse, den Startelf, der dann ein Tor erzielt. Also ganz verkehrt war es nicht. Aber den wirklichen Zugriff im Mittelfeld, der gewünscht wurde, so wie es aussah, den gab es dann trotzdem nicht. War aber trotzdem ein enges Spiel, in dem Feyenoord auch gut und gerne das 3-3 hätte machen können. Am Ende gab es dann mal einen Sturmlauf. Ich hatte ja gesagt, in der letzten Ausgabe, in der ich dabei war, Feyenoord wird Meister. Ich bleibe auch dabei. Wir sind ja nach Platz 1, danke, Tor-Deferenz. Bei Feyenoord, vielleicht aus deutscher Sicht interessant, dass Paul Wanner bislang wirklich gar keine Rolle spielt. Er saß auch wieder nur auf der Bank und kommt nicht so zum Zuge, weil einfach Mann, den haben sie neu geholt, einfach stark spielt, weil Peresic sein x-Ton-Fühling erlebt und weil es einfach ein funktionierendes Gebilde ist, diese Offensive von PSV. Und da dann reinzukommen, von außen ist eh nicht ganz so leicht. Und bei Männer läuft es einfach noch nicht. Es wird oft dann erst in der letzten halben Stunde, wenn die überhaupt eingewechselt sind, sieht er eher unglücklich aus als glücklich oder als schlecht ist. Aber er hat da noch nicht so die Bindung zum PSV. Spielt vielleicht aus deutscher Sicht noch interessant. Und was auch noch spannend ist, das Flamingo, den habe ich ja auch sehr, sehr häufig hier zu Recht auch gelobt in der Abwehr, ist auch eher auf der Bank mittlerweile. Da hat man Gasiłowski geholt aus Valencia, Junker Elfmetalliker, der hat ihn verdrängt so ein bisschen. Und was auch noch erwähnenswert ist als als Punkt bei PSV, Salaheddin. Der ist so ein polyvalenter Spieler, der hat, glaube ich, bis auf im Tor eigentlich auch schon jetzt überall mal auf allen Positionen gespielt bei PSV. Er war jetzt links hinten und hat es auch gut gemacht. Das sind so die kleinen Erkenntnisse auf dem Spiel.
Und dass Saibari jetzt nicht so schlecht gespielt hat bei drei Treffern, das ist ja auch klar.
Genau, jetzt war er der absolute Match-Winner, der, wo man auch wieder sieht, dass der wirklich aus allen Lagen gefährliche Situationen kreieren kann. Der hatte einen relativ spitzen Winkel, ich glaube, beim ersten Tor, beim letzten Tor, beim dritten Tor, hatte er, glaube ich, Lupfer sich ausgeguckt, der genau wunderbar über Torwart und Latte sich reingesenkt hat. Der hat Technik, der hat Auge, der macht Spaß. Und er dreht jetzt auch so ein bisschen mehr in den Fokus, weil ja eben Bakayoko jetzt zu Leipzig gegangen ist, weil auch ein Tillmann zu Refakus gegangen ist. Das heißt, da kriegt er mehr Spielzeit und die nutzt er natürlich jetzt auch sehr, sehr gut.
Das ist sowieso für mich das größte Versäumnis vom PSV. Man hat jetzt Till und Mann auf dem Feld, aber Tillmann nicht. Ja, das wäre so naheliegend gewesen.
Ich habe dich ja gegen Napoli auch gesehen über 90 Minuten. Da, wie du es schon gesagt hast, so viele Zocker und auch Perisic immer noch die Linie rauf und runter marschieren. Und wenn du ihnen Räume gibst, dann haben die also so ein Team, das Spielfreude Stichwort. Und du guckst einfach gerne zu.
Defensiv müssen sie sich immer ein bisschen finden. Das ist nicht ganz so einfach, weil es dann so offensiv ist.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch gut für mich dann immer.
Genau eben.
Noah Lang bereut schon den Wechsel.
Das definitiv.
Schauen wir mal, wenn wir ja unter anderem auch noch gegen Bayern sehen, dann zu Hause. Das allerdings dann erst im Januar. Also wird noch eine ganze Weile dauern. Aber PSV, lohnt es sich im Auge zu behalten. Daniel, du musst weiter. Ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich für deine Zeit hier im Rasenfunk. Bis bald mal wieder.
Ja, bis bald. War immer schön.
Macht's gut.
Du auch. Und wir schauen nochmal nach England. Chris, was hast du uns da noch mitgebracht?
Ja, nun eine kleine Statistik. Ich meine, ich bin es jetzt gewohnt, dass der Rasenfunk mich immer ein bisschen alt fühlen lässt bei den ganzen Spieler, Söhnen oder Trainern. Also Spieler jetzt Trainer. Und da habe ich noch was, um das Ganze so ein bisschen zu bestärken. James Milner hat nämlich Geschichte geschrieben im Wochenende und hat für Brighton eine Vorlage geliefert für Barbies Kostulas zum zwischenzeitlichen 2-3 gegen United. Und das beeindruckende an der Geschichte war, dass es das erste Mal war, dass ein Spieler eine Vorlage für einen anderen gegeben hat, der nicht geboren war, jetzt muss ich es noch in der deutscher Grammatik hinkriegen, der nicht geboren war, als der Vorlagengeber schon in der Premier League gespielt hat. Das heißt, James Milner hat mit 16 sein Debüt für Leeds gegeben. Und als James Milner 21 war, wurde Kostulas erst geboren.
Also 5 Jahre später.
Ich hoffe, ich habe es jetzt einigermaßen verständlich rübergebracht.
Es ist ein ganz wunderbarer Fun-Fact. Und ja, man fühlt sich da bei alt. Aber das geht mir ehrlich gesagt die ganze Zeit so, wenn es hier heißt, ja, mit 35 hat er ja auch so das Ende seines Zenits erreicht. Aber gut, sehr schön, James Milner, der ewige James Milner. Jakob, du hast auch noch was Kleines aus der Liga.
Genau, zu James Milner noch kurz ist mein absoluter Lieblingsspieler und er wird ja wahrscheinlich diese Saison auch noch den nächsten Rekord brechen.
Und zwar?
Den Allzeit-Einsatz-Rekord von Gareth Barry. Ich glaube, da fehlen ihm ja auch nur noch acht oder neun Spiele, um die meisten Einsätze in der Premier League zu sammeln. Also der englische Karl-Heinz Körbel.
Aber wirklich. So wird er auch in der Premier League immer schon genannt.
Genau, natürlich. Ich wollte nur ganz kurz noch über L'Anse sprechen. Genau, die wären, glaube ich, das Hauptthema der Sendung geworden. Vielleicht sogar hätten sie gestern nicht verloren, also haben sich da eine große Möglichkeit verspielt, mit der 0 zu 2-Niederlage in Metz. Und sie stehen aber tatsächlich trotzdem noch ganz gut da, sind voll dabei, zwei Punkte hinter PSG, jetzt nur noch auf Platz 6. Und was besonders bemerkenswert ist, ist der Trainer an der Seitenlinie, Pierre Sage, der hat im Sommer erst übernommen. Da war ja Will Still Trainer, der jetzt in Southampton ja auch nur so mäßig erfolgreich ist bisher, so wie ich gehört habe, ja auch kurz vor der Entlassung sogar steht teilweise. Und da war so ein bisschen unklar, wie es bei Lens weitergeht, aber mit Pierre Sage haben sie da einen echt guten Mann gefunden, der wurde ja in der letzten Saison bei Lyon auch von vielen sehr kritisch gesehen, dass er da rausgeschmissen wurde und dann Paulo von Seca geholt wurde, weil er bei Lyon eigentlich auch super erfolgreich war, hatte die ja damals in der Vorsaison, also 23, 24 meint ich, im Abstiegskampf übernommen und dann noch fast bis nach Europa oder sogar bis nach Europa geführt und dann eigentlich auch einen ganz guten Saisonstart hingelegt. Und er ist so ein bisschen der französische Shooting-Star auf der Trainerbank neben Regis Le Brice vielleicht bei Sunderland und hat jetzt auch tatsächlich historisch einen richtig guten Punkteschnitt in der Liga. Also hat jetzt sein 51. Spiel gegen Metz gehabt, hat einen Punkteschnitt von 1,86. Das ist Platz 13 seit 1932 in der ganzen Liga. Also echt bemerkenswert. Also für alle Trainer über 50 Spiele. Und ja, Lens spielt auch einen ganz ansehendlichen Fußball. Ist jetzt nicht das allergrößte Offensivfeuerwerk, aber sie stehen halt hinten auch ganz gut. Haben zwei interessante oder zwei altbekannte Namen auch dabei mit Ozzon Edouard, der im Sturm jetzt auch ganz gut eingeschlagen ist, seitdem er da im Sommer ist. Und dann natürlich Florian Thauvin, der er sogar so gut spielt, dass er wieder für Frankreich auch nominiert wurde. Und dazu ist Lens auch sehr stark bei Standards. Also da haben wir nochmal die Replik an das Arsenal-Segment vorher. Auch das hilft da sehr gut. Muss man mal schauen. Ich kann mir aber gut vorstellen, dass Lens zumindest auch längere Zeit um die Champions League-Plätze mitspielen könnte und auf jeden Fall durchaus in Europa landen kann. Auch wieder sehr schön.
Die Sage Saga. Sie geht weiter. Ihr inzwischen nur noch drei. Ich danke euch sehr herzlich. Also nie mussten wir schon vorher verabschieden aus technischen Problemen. Daniel wegen terminlicher Probleme und euch dreien, sage ich jetzt wegen inhaltlicher, nämlich weil es das Ende der Sendung ist, sage ich euch jetzt danke. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an euch drei. Majorika, Chris McCarthy, Jakob Haffke. Danke für eure Zeit und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, für eure Unterstützung. Ihr wisst, alles im Rasenfunk ist von euch finanziert. Hier gibt es keine Wettsponsoren, hier gibt es keine sonstigen Sponsoren. Es gibt auch keine Werbung und das alles nur, weil ihr uns finanziell unterstützt auf rasenfunk.de. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Oder ihr klickt einfach auf die Videobeschreibung. In dieser Sendung möchte ich mich bedanken bei Michael, bei Bären, bei Roland, bei Simon und bei Fahnen. Vielen herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Und wenn ihr auch nach dem Zufallsprinzip hier erwähnt werden wollt, dann könnt ihr euch noch registrieren auf rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Und dann kann es sein, dass ich euch hier auch mal persönlich danke. In diesem Sinne, verbreitet diese Sendung gerne weiter, werdet oder bleibt gesund und bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank!